good afternoon and welcome to the
sunrise not the sunrise fari the sunset
safari off to a great start already we
did in fact have a butterfly sitting on
a piece of grass it was a cabbage white
but of course of course it flew away
just before we went live naturally my
name is Taylor mccurdy and I'm hopefully
going to make no more references to the
sunrise Safari and behind the camera
bringing you the most amazing wildlife
footage is a Sebastian feel like it's
been a while since why we just keep
skipping one another funny rotations I
feel like it's sabotage and camp anyways
if it is your first time joining us on
this live Safari we will show you
animals at some point when we can find
them and but in the meantime if you'd
like to ask us any questions you can pop
them through all you have to do is hash
tags fiery live on Twitter and then you
can also talk to us via the YouTube chat
but we're going to get on it so I mean I
can't tell you how long I've been trying
to get butterflies on camera for it's
still look I still have my butterfly
book I've got to do me I'm not gonna
show you what they are the back of the
book two butterfly books
so hopefully sorry yes a bombs went off
the road there with them we're hopefully
two butterfly books we're going to find
some cool things we'll try and check and
have a look at some of the well theories
and the center plants and see what's
lurking on them as well
and well I feel like it's got a good be
a good day to maybe find some
butterflies or perhaps even find a
leopard so I've got some exciting news
for all of you is Sebastian's wife
Shannon was young and she's just she
just left this afternoon in fact just
before drive starts and she said she
bumped into a male leopard from
quarantine how exciting and she said it
wasn't a big male leopard and it sounds
like it's probably going to be horse
Annika she said it wasn't tumba and Shan
knows the leopards quite well in this
area so that's really nice so what we've
done is we basically all the teams are
deployed there's an army unit today for
a search and rescue but not really a
rescue just a search kind of part so we
checked full of ons dipper we saw where
he came up so if you were watching the
sunrise Safari you would have known that
I was tracking him
for the young male infant from cheetah
cut line down number through the
molarity and sort of coming north-west
so that's what was happening so I
suspect that it is him and we saw his
tracks coming out Philemon step so
Scott's also driving around and then of
course the bushwalk team is going to
hopefully be the ones that located but
speaking of Scotty's already starting
the afternoon off with a bird yes we are
starting the afternoon off with one of
the most beautiful little birds called a
little beating you'll notice it's got a
turquoise well you may have noticed that
a bit of kind of a turquoise eyeshadow
very fancy makeup artist and my name is
Scott I'm teamed up with Dave on camera
and as Taylor's already mentioned some
exciting prospects with Hosanna being
seen nearby to where we are now and I'm
hoping it won't take Steve too long to
track him down
well it's not the only leopard that was
moving around Jamaa has been moving
around Juma over the last 12 24 hours or
so in the same area that we are now he
had tracks of both Tandy and Hawk amore
both older more established leopards and
they how cool are these birds they often
like hunting from the same pitch that's
what flowers off once it sees an insect
and then comes back and lands on its
same little hunting podium Lori well
very happy that we've got you your
favorite bird already good stuff so as I
say not the only leopard that could be
seen this afternoon on Juma there was
also Tambor finishing off his kudu kill
as well as tracks of Tandy and hooker
Marie to all the lepers one male one
female
now who can where he ended up quite
close to our southwestern boundary this
morning there's no guarantees they
crossed and I'm actually thinking of
swooping through that area and then
we're not too sure where Tandy end up we
just had tracks kind of around the water
hole where we are here not in the best
kind of area for us to be searching for
her and her cub because we feel that her
cub will be a lot further away from this
area where the hooker marine
al spends time and the reason why is
because he's a new male to the area and
he will kill her cub if she finds it so
that's that and let us continue another
good prospect about this afternoon is
that the Inka Huma pride of lions
weren't too far from our Western
boundaries so lots of big cats are on
it's just a matter of us trying to find
them and as we said earlier with the
help of Steve on bush walk hopefully
that will happen sooner rather than
later why don't you go and see
whereabouts he is on his quest for
Hosanna very excited to share this
afternoon I am Steve Falconbridge joined
by Sens own Kizer and obviously the
legendary and magician Herbie is on walk
with us and we had reports that husana
was seen after drive this morning and
we've come out on a mission we would
like to see him Sally would like to see
him and we got the task of following him
on foot we have found a fresh track here
is the beautiful back pad of a male late
but the easily distinguished three lobes
and then the one two three four toes
where he was seems further off to the
west chair and these tracks come and
crossed the road and sort of head
towards in a general idea Chella pan via
tell a damn so we are with Herbie we're
going to be getting off road here
following these see how far we can go
hopefully we can find him it's always
very very special to find a leopard on
foot and because it's been quite warm I
don't think he'll be too far but you
never know you never know if he's maybe
found a herd of buffalo against chased
them all the way to the other side of
the sabi sands it could happen but as
you know I'm sure Scott and tail have
told you to send to your questions or
comments to hashtag is safari live or
follow us on youtube stream and let's
see are we going to find a sunless
afternoon I have a very strong feeling
we are he is my good friend and he likes
to come and say hello to me if said was
with me he would probably more so but I
think he likes ENSO very well since does
he like you he doesn't like sensor so I
Fillie he's gonna look past that today
since it was looking stylish so maybe
it's interested in coming to see the the
sins or style but we're gonna continue
off here so please come and join us on a
bush walk I hope you have your water and
your binoculars here is another track
very clearly indicating that he's
heading off in this direction
the temperatures been relatively warm
today about 30 odd degrees Celsius in
the high 80s so I mean I don't think
he's gone very far if he's gone he's
gone to drink that's the only thing that
makes sense okay so while we continue on
our mission into the wilderness here
let's go over to Taylor with a net slope
look at what we've got now again I'm
gonna bring reference to the sunrise
Safari is that if you were watching we
stopped and we had and look at a
beautiful kudu bull but he only hung
around for a couple of seconds I'm
almost certain that it's the same could
you ball because we kinda are in the
same spot now look I've focused ears
ears pricked forward not even
acknowledging us eyes focused sort of
down to the southwest I wonder what he's
seen or what he's heard or what he smelt
no he's acknowledging I see that nose
working overtime they're flaring his
nostrils both ears moving independently
as well there could be another leopard
in the area now kudu I've got the most
exceptional exceptional senses their
eyesight is really good their hearing is
phenomenal and so is a sense of smell
and it's one of the animals that we
definitely do trust when we hear them a
liar alarming and also we pay attention
to the kudu to the bush back to the inn
yalla
Linda you said you think that the
security has got amazing horn so do I I
feel like we've been very lucky finding
animals with rather large horns
unfortunately the one was yesterday on
bushwalk and that of course came from a
water bag that is no longer alive and
was taken down on the Lions but how
exciting we actually measured those
horns or Conrad did one of our technical
geniuses and he measured them and they
measured 28 and a half inches that's
pretty substantial for a common water
back this could you I think his horns
Trump the size of the water bags horns
however and they look much longer a bit
I bet they're well over me a meter at
least if not even more than that they're
exceptionally long but of course it's
two different species of antelope and
the kudu has got the beautiful beautiful
twist in them it's Danny he's like a
statue in their story I'm really
intrigued as to what he's looking at in
there must be something and Bobby you're
wondering if he's an older boy yes
definitely I don't think he's a
particularly young fella
I think he's been around for quite some
time and has a bit of experience how how
lovely is that as the did a dead tree
looks like it was once a marauder tree
yeah at some point in its time and it's
very old not nothing even sitting up
there I'm afraid and he just hasn't
moved he's a lovely lovely fella see
look at that look how he's lifting his
head again hmm
well we're gonna search I think we're
gonna spend a few more minutes with us
could you and just listen and watch and
see what he does maybe we'll even take a
drive in there to see if he is looking
at something could be something like a
small cat may be and even a jackal could
even just a water back I mean water
warthog or a Steinbach and he's just
uncertain as to what it is but while we
figure out what the kudu has spotted
let's go across to Scott and see if he's
found any more signs on husana
no we've kind of moved out that area
made space for Steve and Herbie to come
in and do their thing wouldn't it be
nice if he hopped straight onto that
kudos back that tailors but he's busy
sitting with that would be epic what a
showdown that would be now I am
initially going to start off the
afternoon by heading towards where we
last had tracks of the hooker more email
this morning
just to try and establish where in fact
he may have gone and once we've checked
around there if we don't have any luck
then I'll head into some kind of usual
areas where we could expect to find any
tracks or signs of tündi who we are long
overdue or visit from well she's been
visiting us we just actually haven't
been finding her she's definitely been
around so looking forward to trying our
best to work out where in fact she is
each day that goes by that Cub grows so
much that I think we last saw that cub
probably about a week ago and say oh
that cub will be changing quite a lot or
would have changed quite a lot since we
last saw her tell you would like to know
something about menopause in the
wilderness interesting enough there was
a question on that this morning and I
don't know anything about menopause with
anyone Archer maybe tell is the right
person to ask
yeah but sadly I don't even know what
your whole question was but I do know
that I know very little about menopause
with wild animals so just leave it at
that yeah
paife if you could maybe just give me
the question one more time just in case
there's a small miracle and I do
actually know something about it that's
not coming up with anything yes right
now faith
yeah are there any animals that have the
equivalents of menopause in the wild not
that I'm aware of you would think that
some of our primate cousins would be
quite similar to us but that's just me
trying to think mildly rationally I mean
at least you know like our closest
relatives you would think there might be
something similar yeah or - sure
yeah exactly match for saying it's a bit
too much of a girly question for me
so yeah possibly maybe Taylor's better
suited to answering it wonderful okey
dokey well it sounds like Steve is on
the trail of Hosanna so why don't you
tighten your laces and go give him a
hand trying to work out where he's
hiding
thanks Cody yes we are on the trail now
the tracks are sort of headed in a
directly east direction from where he
was last seen this morning look who I'm
with and ban himself Herbert and we are
on foot and we are looking for those
invisible trails remember Herbie's the
karna guy who sees one toe two toes as
soon as we find a track with four toes
we'll do another segment so that we can
guarantee that you can see it but with
this man Roger we're just gonna follow
this invisible trail I think he's
actually smelling the leopard as it
walks which is what you did the other
day to find tumba you found tumba by
smelling the smell of that kudu so who
knows we could find tumba let's continue
on we're doing a bit of concentric
circles here because what you do when
you walk through the bush is you're
looking for any of the sandy patches I
mean if if you just pan that way you can
kind of see the most obvious routes an
animal would take would be that path and
if there's nothing on that path go back
to the fork in the road and have a look
there's another path so that's kind of
the route that the animals like to
traverse on it's difficult to walk
through this long grass as I'm
comfortable for them in the eyes and so
they'll often follow game-pod so that's
what you do you hit in the direction you
see an idea of where they're going like
we were doing with the lions is there we
found them very quickly after it's let's
hope the same is today the case is the
same
so on we go check in the game paths
never to walk on the game path itself
because if you walk on the game path and
you follow in the track and you end up
stepping on the tracks and then you lose
it because the animal can just go left
or right
you need to go back to the last point
you had it's but if you're walking on
that trail it's very hard to go back
because my feet are a lot bigger than
that of wasana if we do step on his
track very easily be eradicated but
think about it there is water in that
direction
it's move in that direction see because
that's kind of what an animal what would
he move for in the middle of the day
water or to hunt and if he hunted that's
very hot who knows he might have been
really really hungry okay so as we
continue to make head or tail of these
tracks let's go over to teller mccurdy
he was driving yeah we moved on from
that could you actually you would not
read into beasts we drove on in to the
thicket to try and see what that kudu
was looking and he didn't move he kind
of just stared at us and then he was
listening to Scott when we switched off
were quite far in the bushes and we
could actually ask Scott on Rebekah's
road to which was really quite funny I
don't know maybe he's just enjoying the
shade as well just relaxing a little bit
we couldn't see anything in my opinion
cuz he's got so much bush around him if
it was something I could leopard or a
lion I reckon he would have been
alarming if it's something small like a
caracal or a jackal there's no need for
a fully grown kudu ball to alarm and I
think he knows that so maybe he was just
staring intently but we could we
couldn't see anything we drove all the
way around in there so we gave it a bash
guess what we did today just quick
change of subject you know because and
we played soccer which we haven't played
well I've never played soccer with
anybody since I've been working rather
we went up to quarantine which is the
big open plains like pretty much the
only open plains on Juma just behind
camp and
we kicked the ball around a little bit I
took more tumbles than I actually spent
time on my feet which was quite funny
ever get lots of grazes all down my legs
now I broke my watch
no more watch that was fun Nikki and I
you know of course Nikki who's one of
our directors we kind of did a classic
YouTube's well normally video that gets
lots of hits where we collided with one
another with the ball between us so like
you know there's big medicine balls we
bounced like that that was quite funny
but we didn't get that on camera he said
not that one I think was before you'd
sit up you know Sebastian maintenance
sets out the time-lapse and then watch
the last and then I tripped over my own
feet for the rest of the game which was
quite funny because that's we had a lot
of fun we're all exhausted though we
played that they crawl over clock during
the day probably not a great idea but it
was there's good fun anyways but sadly
no sign of Masana
know where he is right we're gonna go
through here and then jump up onto in
grey alley and have a look at some of
the mud wallows to see if there's any
animals and Palin you feared how many
animals suffer from heatstroke
it's hard to say hey I dunno I think
would be most vulnerable on an
exceptionally hot day like today sick
animals animals that are already weak
and brand new animals ones that have
just been born will definitely run the
risk of suffering from heatstroke it's
again with the cold shock so the
complete opposite when the temperatures
drop all of a sudden over at night we
see a lot of impacts dying from this the
adults don't necessarily suffer from it
so young animals and definitely and then
I think sick animals may be
exceptionally old ones too
I suppose sure there's been a lot of
elephant activity here today they've all
been pulling out the grass look like
they were kicking in the road trying to
loosen some of the sand to throw over
their body so this might be a good spot
let's see if we're lucky enough to catch
a hood on the move otherwise what I'm
thinking
we obviously saw a really cool herd of
elephants this morning we saw them twice
I'm wondering if they might not pop out
and purfles hook Dan it was quite a big
herd they were on their way there they
went down drainage and did a bit of
feeding so maybe they're gonna go to
buckles look down so perhaps we should
go check there sooner rather than later
Wow oh that's so gross look at that pond
over here
that's not nice at all all the algae on
top of the surface that's not going to
be very good now unfortunately what
happens when algae is sort of forms on
the surface of the water like this often
the plants that are living underneath it
and the water plants they all die
because the sunlight cannot reach him so
all those insects little flies however
and of course forms a perfect spot for
things like these tiny little midges or
flies or whatever they may be sitting on
the surface it gives them something sort
of to walk across normally they wouldn't
be able to do that I couldn't imagine
that would be nice for an elephant I
wouldn't imagine the elephant coming
through here and sort of splashing
themselves with it however a Duggar boy
a buffalo bull would probably find this
quite fantastic Palin you again you said
that this is P looks like pea soup oh
yeah Sebastian you only jump out never
it'll taste what today are you sure
maybe it's a maybe it's a it's like a
good sure it'll be a cold pea soup
mm-hmm we'll give that a skin I feel
like that can give you a dose of bull
hacia in a heartbeat right so I think
we're gonna let bush walk team and Scott
have some fun with that J Leopard and
hopefully I've look we're gonna chase
watering holes and see if we can find
some elephants let's go and see where
Scott is now
good idea Taylor if I was an elephant
I'd be swimming as we speak so we are
getting closer towards the kind of
treehouse warthog basically it's off to
our left
and hoping we're gonna find some further
sign of the cuckoo more email some way
in this area his tracks are very very
close to the warts all literally
probably 50 feet from them and did a
kind of loop around towards the end of
the sapphire but couldn't actually work
out where in fact he had gone hello
very cool bird this the yellow-billed
handle and they look like they are
straight out of a comic book if you try
the one below Davi it's in a bit of
spots and I think it's also got
something in its beak carrying something
there no it was just the Sun glistening
on those fine little tips there
chattering away what are you saying
are you reprimanding your spouse will
bat misbehaving it seems like you really
do have a lot you would like to say to
him or her hard to sex these guys the
other ones got absolutely nothing to say
in return it's just this guy going
full-tilt with the chatting cool so yeah
as I was saying we couldn't work out
exactly where he had gone this morning
this large male leopard we are 99%
convinced that it's him because he's got
one toe that's longer than the other and
for those of you who are on the Sunrise
Safari showed quite clearly how big that
discrepancy is between us toes
basically of their four toes how does it
go yeah it goes like this
kind of now you need to imagine that
this is in line with my pinky and that
these two are supposed to kind of be
level with one another
but this one here his kind of lift long
toe is longer than his right long tire
if that helped you okay good it sounded
like it may have been helpful it seems
like it's on his right foot that the
problem is not a pretty bird yet hello
very fancy outfit where are you heading
off tonight you're going to a very fancy
ballroom dance you look so beautiful I
love me not you said this is a beautiful
bird and it certainly is the speed that
which your remark came through there
nice we think that you could have been
referring to the horn ball but we'll
bill bank both very good both
carnivorous the horn balls and the lilac
breasted rotors I love horn balls on
this they're flying around with a
chameleon in their beak that's a tricky
one for me to to digest I don't like it
when they eat the chameleons but you
can't blame them I guess but I wasted
rollers are mainly insect eaters though
all those small snakes and small
reptiles are on the menu so I think even
a baby chameleon would do just fine for
the sky I thought it was about to to fly
that kind of flinched maybe it's seen an
insect it hasn't done the tell-tale head
wobble it kind of often shake their head
not shake their butt move their head
kind of from scientists I'd lock targets
and then sweep down actually what I'm
gonna try and do here
there's wait a while and see if we can't
actually get to see it flying down and
catching something so we're gonna do a
bit of a steak arch and it often happens
so quickly that if you blink your missus
or if you're just watching at the
regular live speed you can also kind of
miss it so maybe we can think about
doing a bit of a slow-motion replay if
in fact it does decide to do the sweep
thinking about it even if we don't get
catching whatever it wants to catch what
would be nice to do in slow motion it's
just that take off because it's wind
coloration is really really beautiful
when it does take off electric wash of
turquoise Jaime you'd like to know if
that kind of more pale coloration on its
head is for reflecting sunlight away
from them and keeping them cool it may
have something to do with that it may
also have something to do with letting
more light in I know whites around the
eye will help let more light in when it
is low light early morning in late
evening but such a small portion of
white and it's kind of got that greenish
cap on top that I'm not convinced it is
for anything to do with keeping cool but
possibly something to do with letting
more light in are you gonna take off
oh there it goes very good well done
Dave sweeping off to the lilac breasted
roller and we'll see I mean we'll get
the team and FC to see what a slo-mo
replay looks like of that and if it's
any good we'll replace if not we'll keep
trying to get the right shot for you
over to Steve on bushwalk
thanks Scotty is definitely one of my
favorite birds that colorful lolly
breasted roller so we've been in this
block here and hasanah seems to have
been hunting there's tracks of antelope
his tracks have been running and we just
I mean Herbies been spotting just sort
of partial prints of a leopard and then
tracks over of Impala running and so all
around and now suddenly we've got a
beautiful clear track just the back pads
over here if you can see that one two
and three that's a beautiful track of
where he's stopped running he's put his
foot down nicely and we've been
searching around as he's done this bit
of a loop and a spin and a spin now
the tracks are hitting directly in that
direction so once again after he's lost
interest to his loss to the chase then
back onto a pathway and off he goes
again down towards possibly chiller pen
or something like that so we're gonna
keep going on him maybe he was lucky
maybe got quite hungry and he actually
managed to kill an Impala who knows
we're gonna keep following and we'll
keep you updated it's really quite
something trying to track a little bit
because it's just one track through this
through this thick stuff here and the
ground is quiet and the ground is quite
hard off to the rain so all you really
seeing is a little bit of a scratch
Herbie there's a question for you from
Justin Justin would like to know what is
her bees favorite leopard Herbie what's
your favorite lift with my friend
Corolla
it was korilla and now he says it's
Tandy I think she's just got so much
attitude so much spunk and she's a
marvellous leopard indeed and she is the
proud mother of many on the concession
many on the area and her bees been here
for a long time you got something else
herbs ok so once again we're kind of on
a sort of a game path there's some open
sort of patches yeah this is what the
trackers generally like to do as you
walk to an area a dissenter gets thick
again get through that area and look on
these sandy patches and see if you can
find anything but look at what we've got
to work
look at this I mean if even if I walk I
mean that's all you're gonna see of my
entire track so all he's really looking
for is the smoothness the smoothness
that we often find and associated with
the back of elephant tracks that's all
he's got to work with is just a little
bit of disturbance so that's where the
experience comes in a lot of people
can't track unless they see that perfect
perfect track but what people at the
level of Herbie's experience do is
they're just looking for partial tracks
just a little bit of a scuff of the
outside of the foot a little bit of it
as we saw the other day the two toed
leopard that we were tracking fantastic
stuff okay so we're gonna carry on over
here for some reason faith Scott is
talking into my ear again which i think
is not supposed to be happening it's
given me an update on something maybe we
can check that out the terrain is quite
thick the vegetation is is is good for
tracking if you've got a very good
tracker with you but this is not for
their the beginner tracker I can assure
you that ladies and gentlemen this is
for the definitely the expert tracking
the by no means do I put myself in that
bracket okay so we're gonna continue on
here let's go over to Scotty D and see
what updates he has for you
welcome back and good luck Steve on very
envious of the fact that you're on some
steaming fresh and lipid tracks and
possibly the best nippers you could have
to be tracking because you know when you
find him he's not going to be too
concerned about your presence now we've
got some wonderful news the team in the
final control have been very Swift and
efficient with making a small highlights
it's not something we do very often and
I mean I'm not convinced this is going
to be the best one because Dave wasn't
as tight as you would have liked to have
been because when you're expecting a
fast movements and a flag for a cool you
want to give yourself a bit more space
so let's have a look at what it looks
like and you guys can let us know and
just yes any feedback on the thoughts of
highlights just to slow things down a
little bit that we do see in real time I
think it's something that we kind of
been skipping a beats on personally so
here goes
all righty everyone well I hope you
enjoyed that I've got no idea what it
looks like but I hope it was quite cool
and you would have seen that electric
turquoise flash that I was talking about
as it opened up its wings and fluttered
off so Oh hurry along there is something
mating with Steve no idea what species
do you know is that the male is
extremely what I do know is that the
female is much bigger than the male the
males one on the back even if the
viewers out there able to tell me what
species this is obviously it's not too
hot for them lizards are very very in
very very sun-loving and if anything the
Sun has probably made them more active
than they would have been but there's
marvellous these are the things that we
see on Bush walk and tracking a leopard
we have to stop for the smaller things
and we couldn't help but stop and watch
this this is super cool oh it's very
interesting about mice lizards they've
actually got something known as a Hemi
penis which means they've got two
penises but only one will be used at one
time what the purpose of that exactly is
hard to put my head around but maybe
it's for extended periods of copulation
I'm not sure okay copy that faith we are
gonna just hold off speaking for a short
little while as if see get some tick
down and I'd like to do a little bit of
a a broadcast for us yeah wonder if any
of the viewers can send their comments
through the hashtag safari live I'll let
you know what species these are I'm sure
that I've even seen them before
extremely camouflaged
and he's been the male is penting quite
hard they are rather pretty very gray
back legs pretty mottled back but you
can noticeably see how much bigger the
female is de the male she's almost twice
his size there are multitudes of ants
crawling all around the area and it's a
wonder that they're so calm so consumed
with their mating and they're obviously
not hungry there must be some lizard
experts are they
very good afternoon and welcome
there's gentlemen - drew Murr in the
cyber sense where we have come across a
mating pair of lizards I am unsure of
the species and I are dare to go much
closer lest I break up their population
performance this is marvelous to see
we're on bush walk my name is Steve
Falconbridge and I'm joined by sins i'm
kiza
on camera feel free please to drop your
comments in the text below let us know
your thoughts let us know who you are
let us know you're on board if you
possibly know the species let me know
that is a species I am not too familiar
with and the female is almost double the
size of the male and they are quite
enjoying the afternoon there's a nice
warm sunny day with the gentle breeze
coming in from the West and Bush walk in
the big five Safari area we were
actually on the trail of a beautiful
male leopard by the name of asana and we
have halted are tracking for a moment to
stop and watch this fantastic
performance between these two
yes it does but does Richard it does
look like they're attacking the lizard
Abbot it's their chance to it's their
chance to have a go at the lizards
because normally if the lizards were not
copulating they'll probably be munching
down quite heavily on those ants and
also the disturbance that they're doing
by moving along the ground like that is
probably inciting ants to a little bit
of violence should you say they'd always
have a little bit more ego in something
larger than themselves yes Cheryl this
is very cool very amazing indeed I'd
love to know from any of you out there
if you know what species this is for
sure don't have my reptile book on hand
there's probably the heaviest book I own
so it's one I tend to leave it hurt him
we don't find too many reptiles on Walk
and I often take a photo with my camera
and then go back and identify it seems
as if she's a little bit over over the
task and trying to get away but he has
got her class behind the ear with his
jaws and he is holding on very tightly
with his front legs enormous what you'd
call an in green or clasp in frogs I've
never seen this before in in lizards
Elyse says it's a large spiny lizard
that is incredible I've never seen one
before and in fact they are not very
large if anything they're maybe about
the female with her tail is maybe about
10 centimeters now it probably more
probably closer to 15 with her tail and
Gina thinks it's a plateau lizard who
seemed to have some some confusion out
there I hope someone can give me the
correct answer or stomach invalidate
either of the two previous answers
remember folks who are coming to live
this is happening live in the wilderness
she is being almost seems like she's
being molested right now live on TV he
is very interested and what's noticeable
with
most lizard species yes yes Cheryl she
is far bigger than the male that is
often a case in many reptile species
that the female is bigger but hopefully
she doesn't turn around and eat him
after the job is done but I was
mentioning just before we started the
action broadcast that most lizards have
what we call a Hemi penis which means
they've got two penises and only one at
a time is actually used and I need to do
some reading up about that and find out
exactly why they have to it is quite a
bizarre thing really Kathy you asking me
some questions are honest you don't know
the answer to how long will it take
these lizards to produce eggs and then
how long will they take to hatch so
generally I mean if we look at birds for
example birds lay eggs within 24 hours I
would assume that because reptiles lay
their eggs outside their body as well
that the production of the eggs is quite
short in in relation to when you look at
gestation period in mammals because a
lot of the sort of the incubation
happens externally so I would assume
that it would be quite a short
turnaround time for the the laying of
the eggs or production of the eggs and
then the incubation oh she has escaped
his grasp and he is not happy with her
and now he is eating I'm not sure what
he is eating Wow look at their posturing
her mouth is wide open she is giving him
their I think she is saying no means no
yes Linda this is amazing this is
absolutely sensational the lovers have
now parted and now having what seems to
be a screaming match except there is no
sound she is showing a very black mouth
and he was doing something similar it's
almost our de seemed to be very warning
sign she's possibly saying come back
here little man and I shall eat you
and off they go the lovers have parted
and they move off back into the thickets
and so that is it from us on this
live-action broadcast if you feel that
you'd like to follow us further on
safari laughs please google us and
follow us further we still live for
another two hours or so and thank you
for your comments and feedback have a
fantastic afternoon and see you later
how's that folks there wasn't
sensational I wonder if any of you can
back up those two claims on what species
that that lizard was our Herbie has just
been around us here while we've been
talking and he's just done a little bit
of a segment around us here and he's
just trying to find that way Hasaan is
gone okay well we're gonna keep up with
Herbie let's go over to tailor for an
update
well I think that's quite cool that you
got to see lizards mating not always
something that you get to see every
single day now this may look familiar
seen as though we've been here for the
last couple of days in a road that 10
this is where tumba has been but he's
not here anymore
now I know the closest water source to
us is of course for utilidad so I don't
know if he's gone down there to perhaps
have a drink during the day and then
found a bit of shade somewhere else so
we'll have a little scratch around and
see if we win otherwise we'll continue
with our plan of finding finding some
elephants nanu he's gone and at grass is
so tall again he could just be sitting
under any shrub any ordinary shrub and
just concealed by the grass but I bet
he's happy either way because at least
there's a bit of a breeze around now and
so things are going to start cooling off
quite quickly all right watch your heads
even all of you who are watching duck
please no I'm just joking you don't
after duck I have to Dec I have to do
this
judge oh good very good so I think what
we'll do from here is perhaps ooh grab
Gauri cut line and then hit along
bubbles of boundary towards levels of
damn porn er no a question that I'm
unsure of might take a bit of thinking
you've said are there any birds that are
cannibalistic hmm well we know some
species of birds the young sort of
performs a blizzard can enable syndrome
but I don't know if they eat the chick I
think they kind of just kill it and and
that seems to be it any birds that are
cannibalistic I wonder if a southern
ground hornbill if it found its own
would start feeding on it
they seem to eat a variety of things
from carrion so carcasses - chameleons -
tortoises
- all sorts of wonderful things so I'm
not sure what about a vulture I wouldn't
see why a vulture wouldn't eat another
date vulture I mean again they they just
feed on anything they feed not just on
herbivores when they have died they will
scavenge on a lion conkers they'll
scavenge off of a hyena carcass they
don't discriminate so maybe maybe
vultures well but again I'm not exactly
certain I have never seen any
cannibalism amongst birds before I must
be honest maybe we can also pass that
question on to Steve and Scott and
they're in their experience is what I
was trying to get out find out if
they've come across anything like that
would be quite spectacular - I honestly
see something like that I'm distracted
something's resting in the car but I
think it's my present to monitor right
so we're gonna move away from here if
you do hear anything on the dam care
maybe you have vervet monkeys alarming
or perhaps the wildebeest snorting maybe
the go away birds shouting go away let
us know hashtag Safari live because
tombow awful Sanne could head on down
that way for a drink at some point and
it was always useful so from here I
think we're gonna turn up Gauri cut line
now and then go and check bubbles up
damn I really got a good feeling about
the otters look down this afternoon and
if we don't find any elephants I'm
almost certain will at least have some
hippos and maybe some birds to happen
okay maybe that little grieve is still
around right so while we bump our way on
and enjoy the breeze I may pick up the
pace of it we turn the bush aircon on
Scott is probably doing a similar thing
let's go see what his favorite way to
cool down is
my favorite way to cool down is by
drinking a malt drink in the evening
with bubbles in it
very nice and this is a bird of prey I'm
not sure what kind it is from here and
we initially ended up driving off-road
to try and work out why there was a
Franklin alarm calling and then this
bird took off it looks like it could be
a Warburg's eagle and I I can hear you
probably won't be able to hear a few
tree squirrels alarm calling close to
where it's landed I don't see that tall
tail christo that so I'm not thinking
it's the Wahlberg's and I'm thinking it
could be something like a steppe Eagle
that was a fork-tailed ronger that flew
in and through straight past its head I
saw the most incredible clip of a
fork-tailed ronger actually landing on
top of a brown snake Eagles head oh that
was a what is that is that a white crown
Shrike yeah it looks like a white crown
Shrike that was giving it a hard time
there so the neighborhood watches onto
this bird of prey and oh isn't it cool
in this happens they're coming from all
angles now and all the bigger birds can
do is kind of duck down and swallow
their pride as these tiny yet brave
animals hurl abuse at them one of my
favorite things to watch is these David
and Goliath moments with the birds
wonderful well interesting stuff there
with Steve sounded like a really cool
sighting I'm still a bit perplexed as to
the fact that no one knows exactly what
was mating so interesting stuff
[Music]
look forward to watching that when I get
home Susan you'd like to know how many
different kinds of birds we can see here
on Juma and in this general area there's
about 400 odd birds that we can see and
a lot of those are migrants I think
about half of them know can't be half of
them maybe a quarter of them are
migratory birds that come from far and
wide to enjoy this time of the year the
bountiful summer yeah 400 odd birds of
course within the greater Kruger
National Park where you get about 480
birds you get quite a lot of different
terrain and habitats so even though
quite close to here we may find a whole
host of different birds that we don't
get you here on Juma I would say about
400 we don't actually have our own
Safari live bird list that I'm aware of
but it'd be quite useful I'd say we
probably somewhere close to around 250
or 300 birds as a guess that we've
managed to show to you guys
all righty then
well we're about to arrive onto the dam
wall of the twin dams doesn't look like
there's much yeah it seems like worth
telling my plan to try and find action
at the water source has been a bit of a
failure but that means the animals must
be somewhere else very good speaking of
Taylor we're gonna send you straight
back across to her now sorry everybody
we had a really cool sighting of a
juvenile African Harry a walk an adult
was here too but unfortunately not quick
enough this afternoon leave it I feel
like we've lost everybody it's quite
cool it's the first time I've ever seen
a juvenile African Harry a hook before
which is quite nice you soon Hey I can't
even see it sim I'm checking the monitor
that's the adult no and that's a guy's
turn yet look at us no news so there's
the adult African Harry Hawk that
Sebastian spotted so he initially had
the juvenile which was mottled Brown and
it's almost like it's trying to find the
adult because it was calling quite a bit
so what I want to do is while you look
at it I was actually trying to open my
bird up to and look for Harry a hawk I
want to play the call because that
should help us okay let me do that all
right listen that sound that I just
played knows exactly what saben I were
hearing
exactly spot-on and that's what typical
juvenile birds will do I suppose with
young mammals too there will like for
instance lions and leopards that often
contact call to try and stay in contact
with mom or dad and in the birds case
that's exactly what it was Jean perhaps
it was going out on a hunt learning to
hunt that was really nice there but
there's the adult so it's a pity that
you can hear the juvenile I can still
hear the juvenile you won't be able to
hear it though because it's quite windy
and it's exceptionally far away but cool
anyways that was nice no let's carry on
see what else we can find that was
really nice the juveniles look
absolutely nothing like the adults the
only thing that kind of resembled the
adult was those very very long yellow
legs that the adults do you have other
than that it almost looked like a bit
like a pale morphed Warburg's eagle
right so I believe there's some
elephants at chitwan but we're a bit far
away from this I'm not going to make
them - they because I reckon even if I
Ferrari Safari faster than I've ever in
my entire life I don't think I would
make it to them so we're gonna check
before exam and try our luck there and
then if not then we might go back to
what's Gallagher pan cuz they were a
couple of birds and squirrels and things
making some interesting noises around
there as well so we'll try and have a
little scratch around there we don't eat
tiny income or years we don't know if
any of the animals right he's had a very
exciting stories walk but let's see if
he's going to find us a spotted cat
I'd love to find your spotted cat we are
trying there's definite clear evidence
that wasana was hunting and his tracks
are just disappeared I mean look we
really are it is very dense vegetation
it's not too much in the way of open
space on the ground so we're just doing
because eggs eggs and see if we can find
any area where he's possibly walked
again on a straight line and something
that I've noticed as you're walking
through is there are some wonderful
smells in the African bush such as the
morula it's very nice sort of sweetish
sort of smell Marilla but then you walk
along and you stand on something and the
smell is just hmm this plant yeah I
don't know its name oh but it smells
like diesel engine oil and if any of
you've seen this before it's something
that is very noticeable this time of
year this little forb and why would you
smell like that let's have a taste shall
we oh my word that is actually
disgusting it's like a delayed response
in the flavor there ah okay well as you
move along here we go you can see more
of them there's two here is this the
same guy that is not the same guy here
we go there it is there's a few of them
around but they are not being eaten
absolutely untouched as you go through
the wilderness so obviously their
strategy to produce leaves to flower to
reproduce with the most minimal amount
of being eaten because the smaller your
leaves get the list photosynthesis you
get for the sun's rays they're less
sugars and the less fruit and seeding
potential you have so being quite a
small forb coming out to this time of
year they don't want to get eaten and
you saw the look on my face and a lot of
animals would go bust smell a lot of
them just by taste so from my experience
that plant is that leave me alone I will
not eat you palate plot
so thankfully I've got this little
maroon attack which mother my test
I'm only yeah everyone's laugh heared me
that's fun I'll be the guinea pig watch
it I'll be the one who tastes all these
things it's nice to taste them hopefully
I'm not going to die it didn't taste
like diesel I can't explain what it
tastes like but it was revolting
revolting that's all I can say I've
never tasted if any of you ever tasted
diesel before it is probably the worst
thing to ever get in your mouth
sometimes you know our chair we are in
the bush so we do what we call Bush
mechanic stuff and when we full vehicle
sometimes we use a hose pipe to siphon
and if the hose is not clear it's hard
to see once you've you've you suck the
DS and arts of the jerrycan into the
vehicle if you have a hose that's not
clear you don't know when the diesels
coming if you get some in your mouth you
don't want to do that I never want to do
that again and I'm never gonna eat that
plant again either but we're gonna carry
on Herbies just ever doing these execs
we're trying to find this cat let's go
to Scott to see what that Betty has
freedom hello everyone
we've found our nightjar friend that
likes to sleep in the section of the
Malati it always chooses a slightly kind
of different branch when we found him on
Bush walk or her on Bush walk the other
day I'm fairly certain it was it was
actually just right they chase him to
where we are now possibly slightly
behind us but how cool is it's
camouflage in credible and as its name
may allude to it does its business at
night
that's why it's fast asleep now you can
see its eyes closed not a worry in the
world
and Dave if you don't mind resuming
inserts beak it's quite oh we're on max
max volume at the moment are you spying
on us is he cracking his eye open or she
now you can possibly just make out a few
small bristle like whiskers and it's got
a tiny little beak but a very large
mouth when it does
in fact open that beak and those small
little bristles and whiskers help funnel
insects into its mouth when it cashes
them on the wing at night so I'm told
it's actually something we need to try a
little bit more with the IR lights try
and get them catching their prey Monique
you suggesting that this is Little Night
Joe's giving us the side-eye and your
rights how cool is this just keeping a
little eye on us pretending nothing's
amiss now I can't hazard a guess as to
which kind of nightjar this is they're
very difficult animals to identify and
they all look incredibly similar to one
another like oh Allah they don't all
look very similar to one another but a
lot of them do look very similar the
European the Rufus cheek the freckled
and the fiery Nick Knight shall all look
quite the same probably the square
tailed as well so you get quite a few
types and let me show you on my little
Apia it's gonna be tricky to read too
much into these illustrations but
they're all similar looking I mean the
pennant winged is obviously incredibly
impressive and it's got these long
pennants that come off with swings I've
only ever seen one and that was in the
Mara but then if I scroll over to the
next kind of page you'll see that the
way that they help you to identify the
nightjars and this is the only bird that
they'll provide you this kind of
information with is by looking at its
their tail feathers and how they kind of
finish and also their wing feathers so
unless you catch the bird and open up
its tail and its wings to be able to see
that they correlates with the book you
cannot be a 100% certain what you're
looking at unless of course you've just
heard it call that helps
very cool actually I'd forgotten about
long ago think I may have actually found
an eye chart in the same air and I'm
talking over a year and a half ago when
I just before I left for a short one
year sabbatical so I don't know if you
guys can help jog my memory and confirm
that that was the case because if it is
it'll be really interesting to know that
this bird has been hanging around the
same area for at least kind of a year
and a half since we last saw each other
mean obviously we assuming that but I
think it's a fairly safe assumption i
Larimore you'd like to know if it's
posing to try and look narrow like the
branch and yeah I mean I guess so here's
kill this would be quite a nice view
forward a tiny bit that's some serious
side ir5 ever seen it I mean I don't
think they partying are Larimer like a
supermodel to try and make themselves
skinny but I guess it probably chooses
an appropriately thick branch that it
can try and perch itself on to not look
astray okay very good
well we've got some visitors here in the
Milwaukee River but it's Texan and some
of his guests and I just want to point
out to him what's going on yeah because
it's quite a special sighting hello
everyone hello text text there's a night
show just sitting on the branch over
there it's quite nice if you would like
no Leopard sadly okay good there's a
nocturnal bird taxon we'll show you once
you get a little bit closer but you see
the thickest horizontal branch tax just
above that you can see it lying on that
thin branch when you get closer you'll
see it there
alright everyone well we've had a nice
jolly chat with Texan and his guests and
we are now going to be sending you back
to Steve Thank You Scotty so we opened
on in this block we're not coming across
anything fresh from Masada it's very
very to feel even Hobie is struggling so
what we gonna do is we're gonna go down
to the the road that's just sort of
south of us now and go and have a look
at those little pans you know it's
possible he's going to go and drink he
is very relaxed cats on foot to say he
wouldn't even make a noise we might even
be walking right past him but what I
wanted to show you on the way here was
come across some fresh elephant activity
and you know you all out there now I
like to talk about ecology an elephant
has gone and scratched this with its
foot here you can clearly see where the
foot of the elephant was and you see
that here's the track would have used
its foot like this and then picked up
this very fine dust in its trunk and
then thrown it on itself very very fine
dust elephant loved dust bath and you
can see by the way that it's moving
there's not too much in the way of wind
this afternoon it's very gentle very
very gentle so it's exceedingly
difficult to find a cat in this
conditions as well that it's probably
not moving anymore but who knows we
could be lucky but from an ecology point
of view have a look how hard the ground
is over here
as I've spoken about before under car
nice and soft this is over yes or
something in the form of a grass seed
which are just here that might fall in
there and a bit of wind will blow that
over and then you might get a new patch
off of material coming through here
versus over here that is much more prone
to to not breaking through the soil
crust first of all it's very very hard
whereas over here nice and soft very
very easy to get access there to the
ground so just this little bit of
disturbance for an elephant is actually
gonna change the dynamics of just this
little spot quite drastically which I
find awesome really really cool thank we
just love those large ecosystem
engineers I hope you are having a good
time with us this afternoon I absolutely
love being on foot
what is that a little bit of a burrow
yeah that is an awesome burrow
there's awesome burrow but of a sinkhole
oh you know I'm just thankful I didn't
fall in the hole but I nearly hurt
myself on a very cool tree but this is
obviously probably the remnants of an
aardvark that dug in here and then
warthogs are all sorts of things
porcupines would have used this hole and
then at some point the top of it is
collapsed in by what means I don't know
but a very different dynamic to the one
we saw there with elephant scratching
this dynamic has created a much deeper
gali it's also pulled a lot of soil arts
over here you have a look at all the
soil lots and lots of soil you're going
to get a different dynamic different
nutrients from the bottom and who knows
what will happen but different dynamic
from there to there and that is what
makes this event of biomass so unique
and so diverse so we are going to
continue on seeing if we can find some
tracks of this beautiful male leopard
and while we do so let's go over to
Taylor for an update
well you know what the animals just
don't want to be seen today they've
decided it's Sunday they also want a day
off so perhaps it's still Sunday siesta
and they'll wake up a little bit later
and so we check bubbles look damn and I
was right the elephant's actually had
already gone and drank then a little bit
earlier probably a couple of hours
before game drive started and then we've
come all the way down this main drainage
line so in yellow road north and yellow
road south because we were driving here
and we did have some birds alarm and
quite hectically
they were I can't even remember would go
away birds and there are a couple of
others all shouting but no luck no
tracks or no new tracks at least so I
think what we're gonna do now is go
we're coming to the Malati again we're
gonna head towards quarantine maybe you
drive around check a couple of marula
see if we can't pick up on any other
tracks give the bushwalk team my hand
cuz it's going to get dark within the
next hour and a bit so we want to try
find him before they've got to go back
and and then we'll also check around
Gallagher pad maybe some elephants pop
through there for a sip of water or if
another hood comes streaming down to
where Taylor dam at least they'll be
close by and I can race on over there
because I missed them this morning -
otherwise we really haven't seen
anything I saw a daycare that was tucked
away in the long grass I just want to
check it because here's a great section
for tracks and it's sheltered - and has
been quite windy for most of the day so
if there gonna be any tracks around I
should be able to see them nice and
clearly there's also lots of lovely big
trees scattered down in the drainage
line yeah it looks like there is some
elephants here at one point - just
looking lots and lots of tracks on the
ground
no leopard tracks
ah joy you said perhaps the animals have
decided to observe daylight savings time
perhaps perhaps that's the case indeed I
hope nothing come on
animals a picket now she get is starting
to cool down now it's actually really
nice it's really Pleasant mmm I don't
actually know what the temperature was I
wasn't listening when faith told me he
which is not a surprise I never listened
but I'm gonna guess that it was like 55
degrees today at least 34 it was so warm
and I don't know what it would be now
probably about 31 ah so it's 90 degrees
Fahrenheit at the moment so 31 degrees
Celsius not too far off I love playing
the guessing the temperature game and
then of course telling the internet when
it's wrong love to tell it when it's
wrong so another spot gain around this
corner a good spot to check for tracks
lots of tire tracks so many tire tracks
and elephant tracks they could be on top
of their naked tracks that's also what
could have happened just checking very
carefully you'll see me pulling off the
road every now and then doing this
mmm some old tracks here no nothing okay
we let's go to chili pan again and then
we'll head towards open plains of
quarantine Palin you're wondering what
is the biggest insect on Juma I'm gonna
have to say the big stick insects where
she saw one shall we see if we can whip
out an old photo yeah the night in fact
any see if I can find it also need to
give my screen a bit of a clean it was
quite cool with him visited us and then
it sat on the window you get this nice
and clean this is a bit dusty hey turn
it like that I don't know if you can see
it very well the reason why I say that
because it's actually a silhouette and i
zoom in I think you're seeing my
reflection aren't you you can sort of
see it so it's quite big it's like I
said it's difficult to see you got to
look very carefully but there's there's
a stick insect let me demonstrate how
big it was and actually we can just use
my phone I suppose your honor it was
about two of these so that insect was
about a length of a ruler maybe just shy
the length of a ruler with huge wings
and it was flapping around as actually
flew into my face which you know is
fitting obviously it went and did that
so that's what I'm gonna say is the
biggest insect archer and I mean giant
stick insects are some of the the
largest in the world if I'm not mistaken
otherwise the emperor moths are pretty
big too
they're quite nice you see a few of them
oh you know what I would like to see is
a luna moth when it's in a luna moth in
ages I think in fact I've only seen one
since I've been a dreamer which one that
I collected and then we had a cool
experience again we're gonna go up
towards chanted pan and trial-like for a
second time let's go see if Scott is
still animal watch you on a sunset
cruise no we have come out of the more
whitey sadly on some days the signals
just too low down in there so we've come
out so that we can spend time with you
again and striving around hoping to
basically bump into Tandy that's my plan
so I'm gonna drive a few roads where I
know that she has been spending kind of
a lot of her time in general it's a
compulsion just about anywhere but it's
good to use the kind of recent history
when planning your attack and leopards
do especially you know it Sunday with
their youngsters she is kind of using a
few set spots and she's got her areas
and pathways [ __ ] that she kind of likes
to move along so I'm just going along
those chicken carefully for any sign of
them the leopard that Steve and Taylor
actually hoping on finding walked all
the way down this long road yesterday
evening I think I'm actually gonna pull
out my map and give you guys an idea of
what's going on with regards to the
leopards and their tracks that we had
this morning there was just so much
going on that we rushed to try and tell
you guys for you guys in on what's
happening so sideways that's much better
sorry dad ambushed you there dokie
sorry guys I'm just trying to zoom and
we have got some proper maps coming
everyone and that we are gonna use to be
able to show you guys a little bit
better what is happening with the
Leopards of this area and the lines and
everything else so basically where the
center of the kind of map is here this
is where the Viettel Adamas tumba was
just up over there with his kill he
probably still is there Tandy was seen
on the dam cam also in this area last
night and she appeared to come kind of
from the West from quarantine clearings
down towards the dam the hukum or email
we found his tracks coming down this
road all the way over here it's
difficult because it's not really zoomed
in then he headed off to a small little
waterhole and then came back around and
his last tracks were close to the
treehouse water hall which was over here
and hosana came all the way along here
and was left somewhere up there so that
wasn't actually nearly as good as I
would have liked it to be it would have
been so much of a nightmare to zoom in
and give you details so it was actually
a fairly pointless task in that respect
whoops a sweet ride but yeah some proper
more in-depth maps will be coming and
bigger so we can actually show you
what's happening with regards to the
tracks and animals but that didn't work
as I would have liked it to anyway
you win some you lose some
Paul are you wondering what those red
dots were all over the map those are
kind of previous sightings or things of
interest if there's a kill in the middle
of a block you can drop a pin there so
it's easy to find out where it is or to
show the other guides like a mark took
him worries termite mound where he was
waiting for the Warthog weeks caught
that same warthog with Noel because if
you do have his tracks in that general
area it would might be worth just kind
of popping in and seeing if he's not
perched on one of his favorite
restaurants so yeah I mean a lot of
those are from way back when I've only
actually dropped one pin since I've been
back in the last three months and that
was four kumaras warthog Joe well you
said that was informative I didn't feel
it was informative enough but I'm glad
to gave you a kind of rough idea what
was going on it was all just a bit too
cramped in my opinion so to get a good
idea of distance and movement and what
was going on but the bottom line is this
for leopards or at least their war were
for leopards on this property last night
and could well still be the same case
today which is awesome stuff
it's a pity we've haven't been able to
find one of them you have to softy but
we'll get there very good and hopefully
Steve is gonna be the person who sets
off trend of finding the energy go see
how he's getting along
Thank You Scottie yeah we have gotten
back to the area where who be found a
sauna this morning after driving what
this area actually happened last night
to yesterday is we've got evidence here
of what herb is telling me is the
afterbirth or birth giving of an
elephant here's a little bit of the
afterbirth over here and as we walk
through we will see where her sinus
tract is and there's signs of blood the
signs of vulture activity there's lots
of elephant dung here we can see over
here the feather of a of a vulture and
as we walk through this sort of like not
a crime scene because nothing died here
but there's evidence of of this blood
spatter over here well if you can see
that as blackness there's much more of
it over here and as we come further in
where did I see her sonís Trekkie there
was a beautiful track and this is
actually where he found him this morning
here is evidence of serious activity and
here is probably the most of the blood
over here cos the elephant fetus is
enormous
I mean elephant itself the baby weighs
about a hundred kilograms at birth so
that's close to 200 pounds lots and lots
and lots of blood would have tracked at
the likes of a sonic because of the
vultures and as we go over here I'm
going to show you and that's obviously
something you probably haven't seen
before maybe you have it's not often
that you get such beautiful vulture
tracks yeah they are in this perfect
sand here is the track of the vulture
you can see the the toes the pad itself
another back back foot there here's a
beautiful one here so left foot right
foot left foot right foot so let me show
you in the book because this book does
actually have a small vulture track let
me see if I can find it is it in the
beginning yes it will be just here
hmm okay so here you get the vultures
track their 20 centimeters
it says obviously this is not to scale
but if I put that like this you can see
the left foot and this would be a right
foot so this is actually the same we
just move this piece of grass here this
track here is the same as this track
yeah can you see that folks that is
awesome
I've never seen such clear vulture
tracks in my life and that clearly they
were here for the afterbirth as if any
of you remember a month and a half ago
so Tristan had that elephant to give
birth Nia cello pan was just south from
us here on North from us should I say
and the afterbirth was was dragged
behind her and it was a meal for them so
I think that these vultures had an
episode whale of a time who knows if a
signer managed to get in have yet but we
are going to continue on now we where
Herbie last saw him so we're gonna pick
up tracks from here see if we can be
lucky but let's go over to Taylor he's
got someone who made all this activity
in the first place
Oh fantastic you got to see all those
tracks and signs now we're sitting in an
amongst herd of elephants courtesy of
taxon from Juma and kinda called us and
so you can imagine a Ferrari safaried
right over so we could have a look
because we haven't been able to find
anything this afternoon it's been very
very quiet and very dry all the elephant
goes just behind the car so all I'm
gonna do now you okay like that see if I
can reposition for you what do you think
let's see we're just waiting cuz I've
just cause Texans on the sighting with
us to news got some guests that have
traveled far and wide to come and see
these animals are you happy okay cool
Serbs happy I'm just making sure that
he's also comfortable in the car and
what are we eating a bit of sickle Bush
which is really really quite interesting
now we we know with sickle Bush that
it's it's really good in terms of fodder
so the pods are pretty good not to you
and I we learnt that we can't eat them
no that was a wattle water we can't eat
but lots of animals do like to feed on
on the sickle bush and Steve the other
day was talking about all its different
medicinal uses which was quite epic
quite a nice thing to go to chat about
and it's funny
out of all the things that they can
choose that they're going for the sickle
Bush because there's lots of green grass
around there's plenty of the plants that
are even tastier than a sickle Bush and
I think it was up and it was a Maddock
way to say maybe you'll remember where
they're actually having to cut the
sickle Bush trees with molasses to try
and get the elephant's to to feed on
them because there were so many of them
around and even though they're
incredibly good plants for the
environment I was also talking about how
they've got nitrogen fixing nodes on
their roots and I should in fact fixing
bacteria so which helps fix the soil now
elephants of disappearance we might have
to go around and see if we can find some
more and is that they do encroach on
areas and when things like worry trees
sickle Bush even the acacia 's growth
they they will just take lessons and
when they do that
it's a bit of a problem because it's
kind of like habitat loss if you think
about it you're losing the person so you
might find that there's quite a few
rodent species lots of BBC's that like
to eat seeds so some of the larks the
the Weider's the widow bird species they
might have to move out of the area
because there's it's not a suitable spot
for them anymore and so that's another
one of the conservation efforts we do as
guides is not only get rid of all the
alien plant species but we also try and
thin out
some of the encroaching species and
that's actually what Rickson is going to
be doing soon if you don't know who
excellence Rexton is and one also one of
the guides for Juma but he helps us
aren't on bush walks when Herbie's not
around it's going to see if we can get
another view they have moved into the
thickets and taxi they change directions
like three times now so I'm not really
sure where you where these guys are
going if they're gonna go nod towards
turndowns perhaps they're gonna go
towards tree house down it didn't look
like they had a bit of a splash but it's
a hot day so you might need a second
drink of water to quench your thirst
let's see if we can't get another view
of them we'll just grab a bit further
now something that variety videos and I
share in common is the fact that we both
love elephants there are there and
there's amazing creatures they've just
gone in yeah I can see some flapping
ears and other monks the quarry's now
see if we can get a a decent view see
then we're just gonna see bottoms again
we're just gonna see bottoms maybe
there's a little get sometimes if you
sneak forward yes I think Jackson's got
the right spot yeah it's very difficult
to try and view them I'm afraid oh
there's a little baby oh it's a tough
one he said we'll just show everybody
how they're moving into the thicket at
the moment just so you get an idea with
what we're dealing with now for those of
you who are just starting to get to know
me obviously all the guides are
different and we all have our own
guiding techniques which is the cool
thing you get to see the different
personalities and different styles of
guiding now I can't dance that bushes
you can barely see that four and a half
ton elephant car she's not a small car
she's quite large in fact she does have
a little calf at her feet but you
probably won't be able to see it it's so
dense I just there was a little gap at
one point when I got a sneaky look now
the problem over here is that I don't
off-road for elephants ever it's just
one of those things the reason why I
don't offer it for elephants because if
a sighting turns pear-shaped might not
be because of us it could be maybe a
leopard pops up the lion is around a
hyena one elephant is just unhappy a
bull in must comes through and stirs the
herd up you're not able to get away very
quickly
so I don't off-road and this it's a
massive group open grassland area I
might poke my nose in and have another
look but for an area like this I'm not
going anywhere near them I'm afraid and
you know that's we'd go and view lions
and leopards so we're gonna let them be
they've now changed direction completely
yeah I think they might go to twin dams
but they've still got a little bit of a
way to go man let's see if that
squirrels gonna cooperate yes hang on
saving we go forward little bit so just
below the fork of the dead knob thorn
tree yeah I can't see him anymore it's
just gone around but he was sort of
serpentining right around an entire
chair Missy if you're gonna poke his
head out again there was a tree squirrel
moving about there we go well spotted
so camouflaged I couldn't see the
squirrel just looking at the tree very
camouflaged against all that wood so
that's where it disappeared not only was
it serpentining around the trunk of the
tree it was a popping in and out of the
holes and that's a perfect habitat for a
squirrel for things like Janet's for
lizards scorpions owls
it's amazing what you would be able to
find even maybe the odd snake a snake
that was able to climb up trees would be
good that is really really cool sitting
very still just sort of having a look
around probably was down on the ground
searching for marula nuts because that
seems to be what the squirrels are
feasting on at the moment
they'll also start stashing them because
during winter obviously and they're not
many fruits and seeds and nuts and
things available so they need to make
the most of it and start stocking up so
that's what we're typically seeing at
the moment and a little styling also
just off to the left very nice Lizzie
you say that this is so cute it is it's
quite beautiful when you get to see
something like that so how's that in
that massive tree that once was alive
but sadly the reality is that probably
an elephant ring barked at and has
killed it but it will still stand for
many years later it's still providing
life to many other creatures even though
it is no longer living and I bet that
that squirrel is thankful for this tree
at least it can be a little safe haven
keep it warm in winter all those cold
chilly nights and dry from the rain and
also
be able to hide away from any birds and
snakes right Steve is still on foot and
he's not looking at a plant this time it
seems he's got something with the
heartbeat
indeed it as a heartbeat and they seem
quite relaxed to me we came down to the
road that was just sort of east
southeast from where we were in the
block to see if we can find any activity
of potentially the young Prince coming
out and maybe drinking at one of these
pans we had Tandy and a cub drinking at
these pens not so long ago but yalda
seemed quite relaxed I mean we were on
foot right now we've managed to creep
that's about 40 or 30 odd yards from
them and if they had seen a leopard I
guarantee you they'd be showing us that
behavior that indicated a little bit
more sort of worried about their life
because this is one of the leopards
favorite foods indeed isn't that
beautiful see if they were not relaxed
they'd be standing very very still
trying to blend in with the background
but probably probably the most beautiful
antelope that we have makes the kuru
this is my second favorite antelope I do
love the sexual dimorphism exhibited
between the male and female and the
females are this nice sort of light
reddish brown color whereas if you
haven't seen it before the males have
horns in our chocolate chocolate brown
with a beautiful white mane on the back
of the neck
mrs. left-wing I love your name yes the
stock the back the dots the spots and
the stripes are very very gorgeous in
Yala very specifically I mean push back
are also gorgeous but they don't have
the same white stripes as than y'all do
and it just are really really pretty
animal nature is awesome you see how
they walk if you watch that female
walking there you can't really see it
clearly but as she walks her front foot
she steps directly on oh hello that was
a bit of our ji bhaji looks like a guy
into a little pan there to drink one at
a time one keeps their head up and is
poised while the other one drinks and
what I was saying is as they walk their
front foot their back foot steps exactly
where their front foot stepped
characteristic behavior for the Traeger
lifeís family meaning spiral horned
family which you see in kudu bush buck
and yalla Eiland also will directly
register and it is obviously a means of
walking very quietly and you see the
huge enormous is that is their primary
source of predator defense is to stay
undetected through camouflage and to
hear what's going on imagine what you
would hear with those huge satellite is
we are getting some very interesting
names through today magic dragon wizard
I love that name there is our super cool
super super cool you imagine what we can
hear with our ears you can only imagine
what these guys can hear with those
enormous is proportionate to their face
ok well it seems like Taylor has been
very lucky let's go over to and see who
she's found I can't take any credit for
this not even a small amount again this
is all Texan I'm just gonna follow Texan
around the Softee he's found hooker
Maury though this is the leopard the the
long-toed male
that Scot was following or trying to
follow his tracks this morning and was
probably just watching him as he moved
around and was been quite hot but like
we said it has cooled down quite nicely
now although he's still panting quite a
bit trying to keep nice and cool now
this is only the second time that I've
seen this male then he's beautiful let's
see can you stop and have a look
still got that cuts above his left eye
which he's had now what a couple of days
at least or maybe a week look we might
lose visual just because there's another
vehicle I think gonna drive straight
through our front please don't do that
okay good car they pulled off to the
right there we go now this is where the
tricky part comes in isn't the area that
he's heading into now is particularly
dense and it's actually a spot that we
often go and try and find leap it's when
we're at tree house down so that's where
we are now he's heading up the drainage
line so we might lose him in a little
bit well he'll probably have to do some
serious off-roading to try and get back
to him but have a little listen all the
birds are starting to alarm at him now
like able to hear them sounds like a
spur fall or a Franklin that's not
particularly happy with him
he's an old older boy though not
interested in a small bird like that
very unhappy another one a flying town
get off the ground sit in a tree you do
that scared this is beautiful
and st. marking sorry everybody
well you know have lots of vehicles
passing us unfortunately this is what we
have to deal with there he is he's just
popped out to the left I know he's gone
behind the car okay this is a disastrous
now and it see if he's gonna walk no
we're not gonna get another vidas cars
are blocking our shots yeah I'm just
trying to figure out what we're gonna do
from here now is whether we go up ahead
and try and find a way in otherwise I
think we're gonna get stuck behind the
cars right let's go it's just Scott
though while we try and figure this all
out and see how he feels that it was
basically right in the area this morning
yeah it is interesting is it not and
just so nice to know I mean there's a
chance he moved away from the water hole
and then came back to it but I'm
guessing he was just lying around there
watching us walk around scratch our
heads actually essentially we parked the
vehicle there got after the big loop
around found his tracks followed them
back to the Dan did another loop around
came back again all this time is
probably just sitting in the grass
keeping an honor on us then this
afternoon we drove past but all that
matters is that he has been found now so
that is wonderful news and let's see if
we can't find any more leopards like I
said there was four leopards and Jim
last night one has been found now
tambour I'm thinking is gonna be a bit
of a
of time to be honest because he's so
full I'm not expecting great things from
him
and I think it might make more sense to
look for Tandy and/or Hosanna and all
the Inca Houma pride of line which could
cross in from our western boundary I
think that's where the money is gonna be
so that's probably where I'm going to
try and position ourselves Bobby I don't
have the faintest idea why illiquid
earlier rosettes on their body and not
their head i guess there'd have to be
very small tiny miniature rosettes which
would be possible for to fit on their
head but I think spots I think it's just
yeah I don't know we'll have to ask
Mother Nature that question when she
designed them
come on tracks
Debbi you like to know if male lepers
will become predictable on the pathways
that they travel along when
scent-marking
yes to a degree and some more than
others
I think each male will vary in a style
but yeah I think as a general rule they
kind of do have some pathways that
they're like to move along and hopefully
we'll be able to see the hook I'm
worried male well you'll be able to see
the hook can wear any male doing just
that a little bit later on this evening
and that is where we're going to send
you right now we are with him he's
coming right up in front of the car
that's horrific he's walking right past
us he's so relaxed and he keeps giving
us that psycho what did we say if looks
could kill it would be his in a
beautiful psycho
I think somebody referred to him as and
I think that is so fitting what a cool
cat now let's hope he does as usual and
starts checking termite mounds he's
excited for that I think he looks like
he could eat a warthog and from what
we've seen well from what Scott seen
from what Steve is seen he seems to
specialize and in fact hunting warthogs
he's just standing there so let's
reposition I don't even know he is oh
he's off to the left I was laying flat
in the car looking at the monitor we'll
just go back a little bit and then we'll
go around
hee-ha we're lucky we're actually
winning because we're so nimble with no
problem faith oh what's he seeing here's
what pricked up there they could also be
scrub hairs and things lurking in the
grass he was just sort of twitching his
body slightly so I don't know if there's
something maybe there i slinking through
can we reposition and gain for us we're
gonna be doing a lot of this everybody
is going forward going back
that's how you get over log everyone oh
well I'm jealous I'm jealous I hope you
get ball get the most amazing
screenshots cool breeze you're wondering
one of the big cats pants so much well
it's it's a way that they'll try and
keep themselves cool big stretch perhaps
he's scratching his clothes on a log as
well and so it is it has been really
really hot so they will be panting
you'll even see the birds today with
their beaks a gape trying to cool
themselves down it's gonna roll back
slightly for taxes managed to squeeze
pass a tax also wanting to get a good
view for his guests but at least he's
now a come art on the road and that is
how a leopard leaves footprints on the
ground in case you were wondering look
how amazing that is step by step you
can't hear a thing as he walks along the
ground either silent a silent killer he
seems to be on a bit of a territorial
Patrol obviously he's been sent walking
we you then had the wonderful scent of
popcorn a couple of times but he's gonna
be stopping and listening like oh he's
nice you know his behaviors changing
perhaps he's heard something seen
something smelled something
every time he thinks he has an
opportunity to make a kill or
potentially stalk an animal he's going
to go for it as most of you know
unfortunately the big cats are not the
most successful hunters archer so it'll
take them a number of attempts before
they were lucky I reckon he's just been
resting up after Scott tracked and round
and round this morning I bet he was
exhausted after his evening patrol there
he goes again
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's been working the camera for a few
years they love that casual pad to the
sky marilla trees very pretty yes he's
just gonna go around the corner so we'll
try and play catch up with him again and
get another view of him wow wow wow what
a treat for this afternoon not to Sanne
I'm afraid but at least it is it is a
lipid I mean she's just looking at his
long toes now I'll find a decent track
and have a little squeeze right we're
gonna try and catch up with them and
have another look
Scott however has got my favorite animal
well awesome stuff and happy mail is on
the move let's hope that Taylor can
stick with him it can be quite tricky in
around the treehouse waterhole there we
found ourselves a very cute scene of a
mother and her young calf and clearly in
the long grass is not too much to see
just yet but it is quite small and it
actually just tripped over a little
branch a little bit earlier on its way
to where it where it is not too sure
what it's doing
other than flapping its ears every now
and then what have you found there are
you playing around with your log
over there a termite mound definitely
investigating whatever that is quite
intently and when they are young like
this they don't have perfect control
over their trunk just yet so there's
been a lot of time kind of playing with
it and trying to get to grips with hard
works
and happy to hear that lots of you are
very happy to see this tiny little Bubba
Oh looks like it's about to put on a bit
of a show for us it's getting a bit
worked up yes we're talking about you
but everyone's very happy to see you so
don't be shy or embarrassed you don't
need to run off back to mom but I think
you want to I think you've been a bit
far away for mum with these strangers
here and it's fine you can hit on back
to her going a little bit panicked a
hard time come and charge us come and
show us all big and strong you are come
on I know you want to here we go come on
come on show us up big and strong you
are I think it felt safe there close to
mom but just like a lot of young animals
elephants can be incredibly playful
what's a sure way the rest of the head
is it's just the two of them that we've
seen for the time being and maybe mom is
just taking it slow because she does
have this tiny baby alongside err they
can't communicate with one another were
quite big distances through infrasonic
communications so she won't worry about
losing the herd Pizza Viper you'd like
to know if elephants give birth lying
down I've never seen an elephant give
birth I've arrived minutes after and I'm
guessing it'll be similar to a lot of
animals it can be done either lying down
or standing up so probably a combination
of the two depending on the individual
female you'll probably find that this
may be the majority of them are born
standing up where gravity can
Syst but just like the wildebeest we saw
gave birth this year
Tristan's one stood up and gave birth
and the one that I saw giving birth was
doing it flying down with far more ease
actually the interesting one standing up
but that could have been for a host of
different reasons
maybe the female was older and had gone
through that more process a few more
times well possibly the calf was just a
little bit smaller and popped out a
little bit easier
I know effect effect Indian elephants
give birth standing up sir guessing that
African elephants might be similar to
that I saw a video of an Indian elephant
giving birth not so long ago that was
quite quite fascinating actually
clora
just ten years old you'd like to know
what age will elephants have their first
baby and I'm guessing it's somewhere
between count of 15 and 20 years of age
but just like us as humans there's no
set age and people can have children a
little bit younger and some people can
have children when they're a little bit
older and it's very important to
remember that klar just like you and me
we each our own person Archer nature all
the animals although they look the same
to us they are all their own individual
specimen they've each got their own mood
and character and I guess just like when
the elephants look at us we all look the
same to them but we're all different
even though it might be ever so slightly
very very good I killed it sounds like
Ted has managed to keep up with hooker
Murray so why don't you race back and
see what's going on there well he's
actually stopped luckily we were able to
keep up with him you might believe what
happened
typical kitty cat nice sitting in the
grass is that he spotted a mess of COBOL
well I feel like the kudu ball actually
kind of spotted him first didn't say a
word
sack very very quietly a magnificent
bull kind of like the one that we saw a
little bit earlier but even the thicker
neck and more muscles on the shoulder
and he just sort of stood and looked at
her Maury and then took towed away into
the thicket and as he was tiptoeing
where I think he made the fatal mistake
of crushing a few leaves with his feet
and then hooker Maury picked out that
sound and got into a trot and then just
ducked down into the grass but he
doesn't look like he's stalking him
at all he's still just sitting flat
perhaps just taking a little moment and
little breather he does look hot he does
look a little bit bothered so male
leopards will do that female epital do
the same thing when they are on a patrol
walk walk walk see it was lions sit down
get a carry on walking market territory
that whole shebang so now we kind of
just waiting for him to make his next
move we're we're heading to you
we are going back basically towards shoe
bomber and there's a couple little pansy
and they're nice and open so let's keep
our fingers crossed
pasties really had a drink a tree house
damn I'm not really sure I think I said
on a hot day like today often you get a
second opportunity to see the animals
drink and you know he might take it and
it's beautiful golden right now so let's
hope he actually gets on the mood but it
is it's a difficult spot there's quite a
few vehicles and so we aren't able to
get in where he is there's also lots and
lots of trees that have been tipped down
I'm afraid when we go there's a sunset
but now we kind of just have to sit here
and wait for primordia to get up and
start moving again and and who knows how
long that's going to be it could take
him 10 seconds it could take him two
hours before he makes his next move but
that is stunning I think we're in for a
treat this evening with a sunset all the
clouds that are down in the West I think
and maybe the odd marula tree or dead
nob thorn or dead lead word that is
going to create some beautiful
photographic opportunities for all of
you who are watching remember to always
take screenshots it's important to keep
those screenshots memories and then of
course you if you'd love to share them
with us you can hashtag Safari I don't
know maybe we'll even have a sunset
competition because I think we're gonna
be lucky today and so we'll try and get
the sunset when it actually sets on
camera in a little bit and I'm pretty
sure that Scott and Steve will be game
as well and will probably enjoy that but
that's stunning
and it's quite nice a said how all the
caterpillars have been feeding and those
silver cluster leaf leaves so you can
actually get the light coming through
so there's little holes caused by the
caterpillars that's really really
amazing so so beautiful very lucky we're
gonna sit patiently like I said and hope
that hookah Mori doesn't stay down for
too long
and while we wear our patient pence
let's go across to Steve's to see if
he's having any luck with the other
Leopard
thanks very much Taylor I'm super happy
here it's a fun hookah Moody
apparently the long-toed leopard cat as
I would love to find that track and see
her be said if we find one he'll show me
how he's got such long toes so there
would be quite interesting life is a
photo measure it compared to other
leopard tracks but we came down sort of
sort of south or east from where we were
we've checked a couple of pans it
doesn't need to be anything going on
here with regards to tracks of the
little prince or son of the leopards and
so we are slowly gonna go back the Sun
is stunted to sit in the West we're
gonna go back into the block he doesn't
appear to have come out of that block so
we're gonna go back in the block one
last-ditch effort to see if we can find
him on foot wouldn't that be a marvelous
surprise talking about surprises what I
love about this little pod yeah the
russet bush Willa is how you can do this
and look at that a little surprise now
this is the russet bush Willa you want
to pool that seed out throw it away boil
some water drop a couple of those in
your teacup and you'll have a nice
tasting tea marvelous okay so here is
the surprise the roasted bush willow and
it's wonderful it's called a Samara and
you peel it open isn't that marvelous
inside is the seed which you must throw
away otherwise you drink the tea and
you'll get hiccups
isn't that beautiful Adam party trick
for the day so if a thought I got the
question you've posed there but I didn't
get the name of the view if you could
repeat the name of the viewer please
inferred infernal apathy we have got
some really good names coming out today
how am I so chilled this is what I love
doing
infinity I love being on foot I'm in the
company of two amazing gentlemen we're
having good conversation
we're walking we're just having a bit of
a Sunday stroll as it would be and this
to me this is my element yeah yes I
can't hear out of this year which is
probably the only daunting thing about
being at you've got Herbie is an expert
tracker he's got is of absolute niala
potential and the smells the sounds
everything I just love being out in
African wilderness a lot of people think
this is the dangerous place to be but I
understand this place I understand the
animals behavior they're not actually to
get us I struggle to go to a city
because people are the dangerous ones
watch out sends behind you people are
probably the most unpredictable mammal
creature in the world they're cunning
they're conniving I don't understand
people so this is for me the safest
place in the world to be if you don't
understand something it's hard to to get
your mind around it but when you
understand it everything has a place
cities and people and all that they
freak me out a little bit so I got some
some comments through about those
lizards ornate rough scale lizard seems
to be the species a friend of mine
actually a student her f very cool dude
who are often visiting Cape Town he now
takes me birding which is cool he sent
that foo to me I haven't managed to
check Twitter but that seems to be the
gist of the lizards but please keep your
comments coming through see if we can
correctly identify to only be able to
check myself as we get back you okay
maybe okay so the Warburg's pair are
back in the tree up there with the
youngster the nest that they were with
is just off to the right and it seems
like they are back for a little reunion
maybe to see how the youngster is faring
on its own
grooming their which is interesting but
we are going to leave these Wahlberg's
gonna go up to Scotty D who's got the
largest mammal on land so still with
this le cow and her young calf certainly
they've just kind of veered off a little
bit away from us and you'll be glad to
know they're not completely alone we did
see another kind of teenager trailing
behind them I'm not too sure where that
one's ended up so I'm sure the rest of
the herds somewhere in the general
vicinity and a beautiful wash of golden
light on this wonderful wonderful
evening it's nice and cool now this is
definitely the time of the evening when
things start kind of heating up with
regards to action and cooling off with
regarding temperature very good we're
gonna keep moving along cuz we don't
have the best view of them from there
not too sure what to do
actually I'm torn as to whether it's a
gun lingering around and wait for the
inka Huma pride there's been no further
sign of tündi sadly despite checking a
whole host of roads where I was
expecting we could possibly find some
tracks I'm not convinced by going to
tumba but maybe we can swing past there
now quickly on route to where the lines
will cross if they're doing fat crossing
a little bit later Oh bumpy roads jiggle
the camera loose there so yeah I think
that's a plan sadly no joy with Hosanna
clearly as you've gathered from Steve
I'm not too sure what the latest update
is there but to honest it's just so
tricky following tracks through the
blocks at the moment of all the thick
grass and the rain that we've had
relatively recently
so they haven't had an easy task that's
going to but I'm guessing it's gonna be
more sleeping than anything else
all righty over to Tina
sorry shape Scotty the gremlins are
getting you listen I don't think Alma's
come across and show themselves cuckoo
Maury has been sleeping but I think he
might be coming down the road now oh oh
treat with me trees shark teeth in South
Africa and where did he go where did he
go let's have a little squeezy here I'm
waiting for text to point him out to me
because I don't actually know where he's
gone it's Aspen ears is he still going
oh he's in front he's on the road that's
how you spot lepers you see that let's
see I'm trying to think what's gonna be
our best bet if we should we're just
gonna stay behind Texans in front of us
these dates are having the most
unbelievable sorry lucky then that they
got such a great guard come on we coming
up to those mud wallows now I really
want to get in front of him because we
want to be with that golden light let's
see what he's gonna do he's just up
there
he's again just having a little look
around campus you wanting to know if
Hawker Mori will kill husana if they
meet I most certainly I don't think
hooker Mori will give any of the young
males around a chance like ting garner
did or even in fact in Pula he's a new
male to the area this is unfamiliar
territory well he's starting to get
familiar with it now but he's not going
to tolerate any of those young boys so
they need to be careful and hopefully
all signer will realize this because
unfortunately he's not gonna give them a
second chance
he's just st. marking now I'm hoping he
doesn't cross art you know what we might
do save I want to get around let's go
I'm taking this gap yeah behind this car
we're gonna do some off-roading hold on
put your seat belts on everyone we're
gonna do sabi sand maneuver we Ferrari
Safari hold on to my camera and watch
branches I want that golden light on him
all of you see ya dude for the fans and
then also hope we don't break the car in
the process yeah we've got little nimble
vehicles no one else can do what we can
do sorry Sebastian's holding on for dear
life
UK they said don't lose your camera but
I'm jeanna for you as well see if I'm
gonna get you in the best spot you know
me know we're in front of him
hang on I just don't know what he's
gonna do he's gonna go down that pathway
if he is sick I'm gonna go wrong the
other side of the pan he's I think he's
going okay so you can see him sorry
everybody I'm trying to figure out he's
gonna drink yeah and then if that's the
case let me just show you here we go
this is how we do make sure we don't go
rolling into these little pads he's
deciding it's a pity even those clouds
are saying how wonderful they were kind
of wish there were a few less because
that golden light is now starting to
disappear but never mind I still got him
looking straight at us come on boy come
and have a drink right here it would be
ideal there we go but of a golden glow
on him isn't that lovely
look at that stunning coloration he's
always got like jag you I like markings
don't you think well that's what I think
in fact sure we spoiled this afternoon
absolutely spoiled come on boy you're
walking right on the edge of the water
stop and have a little drink for us look
at that reflection - no not having a
drink that is amazing an inverted image
beautiful whoo
there we go how cool was that that's how
we do Anka said that's a little sneaky
maneuver there he's just going around
good boy don't cross out just yet
now Aiden who's only six years old I've
been loving your questions lately thank
you for all of it you've said why won't
this leopard just be nice he needs
friends Aiden I agree but unfortunately
he does not he does not understand that
you see for him he doesn't want to keep
tumba or husana around because he's not
the father he's not the dad so he would
rather take them on and remove them from
the area because they're gonna be
competition for him one day to remember
this male leopard is not coming he wants
to try and kicked in Ghana I'll choose
the resident King and he doesn't need to
have any more competition and that's
what hasanah
and tomba are their competition to him
so he will want them to move out of the
area those epic that was amazing well
are we gonna try oh my goodness we're
gonna try and get another view but
without further ado I think Scotty D is
hot on a spotted cat
we are indeed you've got a bit of a
surprise for you guys
and while you're with hookah mori we
thought I'd just position ourselves in
an area that if our surprise was to
continue towards us we would have got
some great low angle views of it but it
appears that it hasn't it's taken
another route so we have to just work
out what that route was or is sure we
all find it somewhere around one of
these corners if you don't say I'm gonna
feel like a real moppets it's a sauna
and you wouldn't believe it but he
actually came as we turned off onto the
off-road tracks that led up to Tom
buzzkill we found him which means he was
definitely in that area and I'm almost
tempted to rush back then see what
Humber's up to because if he is still
there which I'm guessing he will be
it'll be really interesting that husana
gave in to him because susana is a
little bit bigger and we just reposition
again now he's trying to sneak his way
down to the voyeur till a dam here
without being spotted by anything
there's not nearly as much game as there
usually is down here but there's one in
Yala that he's spotted that he's trying
to avoid
I really am frustrated that we missed
out on whatever happen between him and
tumba and I guess it proves my theory
completely wrong I was expecting there
to be no action with tumba yet
completely the opposite was the case
because there would have been some
fascinating interactions to be able to
capture and witness and share with you
let's move again ah Jersey lady you
doing your happy dance that's wonderful
to hear
I wonder if timber wasn't actually not
there possibly of having a drink
somewhere novice lipids checking very
carefully to make sure there's not a
leopard here having a drink anything is
possible I'm just assuming that timber
was in fact on sites I think what he's
looking at and you can see his very
intent to summon Yala bulls that are
behind us now he's just gonna attempt to
swivel all the way around and show them
to you there's two different sets
there's the one over there and then two
further off to the right of him and that
is who young husana is keeping a close
eye on was that three there yeah three
there he doesn't want to be seen by them
because they'll start barking I've got a
dog like Bach and I don't he doesn't
want to give away his position
he looks fairly hungry so I'm guessing
that's why he's trying to be extra
cautious
hello boys
yes Janicki certainly is a beautiful and
regal cat both him and tomba are fine
specimens and you tend to find with
leopards the young males are very very
appealing to the eye
and as a general often as they've become
older it's possibly less so they become
a little bit banged up and bruised and
scarred and battered but between him and
Tama there are two exquisite young male
leopards this guy's slightly older than
tumba I'm told and his eyes are quite a
different color tom has got more of a
greenish hue turds I then old Hosanna
well Chris you said he looks rather sad
and I guess yes he probably is a little
bit sad and disgruntled because he knows
there's another lipid around the corner
that's still snacking on some cootie
well he's got nothing really attempting
to stalk from here shortly buddy get to
the program what have you seen close the
bar because they're in Jana is about 150
meters we're not even a cheetah would
attempt to stalk it are you gonna go
under our car I think you minds he's
gone under the back corner I'll try and
get a picture quickly of his tail to
show you guys but he should be popping
out literally underneath Dave at the
moment stalk mode because whatever
you're trying to catch is miles away and
I'm told the bush Walker busy spying on
us I'm not too sure where from there
must be something closer by in the grass
it's the Egyptian geese on that mound
there Davi
Oh they've spotted him already they're
already starting their alarm call you
see something there that was pathetic
cuz I know what was X what was that what
are you attempting to jump on there okay
very good well why don't you guys see
exactly where Steve is sniping us from
thanks Scotty how special is that I'll
surely try to catch their look like a
yeah yeah yeah relax with Lapwing so we
went back into the block and we found
the tracks of a sauna coming north
directly towards for you Teledyne where
I had originally thought he might come
because he'd run a drink Eriksson joined
us much early in the drive him and his
tracker drove around the block and
assured us that he hadn't crossed the
road that's why we stayed in that block
but on tracking him out we found very
clear evidence of where he trekked
across yeah and now all Scotty's found
him before us so terrible as it is Scott
has found him but we have been on his
trail for some time the last 15 to 20
minutes so just be super super cool and
it wasn't that marvelous
okay well Scott's obviously got a much
better look at him so it's good him and
see if he's having a drink
welcome back everyone and this one make
sure that Taylor knows that being cool
pride on the property because hookah
Maria is now crossed arts of our turf so
maybe she can race across there and she
does know about that so that's the good
news so she's gonna hit off and see if
she can't find the liens and are we
gonna stay here and I'm just gonna keep
quiet for a second we're actually be
able to hear him lapping up the water
thirsty boy
look always trying to remain undetected
sadly those key so I'm coming from a
long way off they're moving just over
there in the grass tricky to see but
they're there and wouldn't that be cool
watching I'm trying to catch a goose
does happen from time to time but they
do get lucky with the birds something
I've never actually seen happen but it's
something that I would love to see
there's a lady you said it's good to see
him on the damn cam it's probably been a
while
he usually kind of stays furthest off
then here this is definitely the closest
I've seen in two camps since I've been
here for the last three or four months
he's generally kind of hung along after
more southern boundary and you would
have spent a lot of time here growing up
I'm sure lots of you will have lots of
happy memories
what are you like to know if for sauna
is the most social of all the Leopards I
wouldn't be able to answer that question
I haven't spent enough time with him
interacting with other other Leopards
and I don't think yeah I mean he has
spent a lot of time with his father but
whether that's because it's father
tolerate some more yeah I mean it's just
a tricky question for me to answer and I
think to be honest for anyone to answer
because none of us spend enough time
knowing exactly what goes on with these
animals we're now almost active after
dark so there will be too many missing
pieces of information for anyone to
categorically say who the most social is
in my opinion
and again a lot of the time it's
probably more through default than
anything else that he will come across
other leopards or other leopards will
come across him
Liz you said the tip of its tail seemed
like it has a mind of its own and yes it
does to chain from side to side I love
watching the tips of their tail moving
about evidently not finished with these
Egyptian geese yet and he's trying his
best to sneak closer to you them closer
than that buddy but maybe you just want
to lay in ambush from here maybe that's
the plan
okay everyone we are going to be sending
you back to Steve thanks Cody how
marvelous is that well done well done on
finding that beautiful prints and I'm
sure he's feeling much better after
having himself a good drink so our
assumptions were correct that he would
have moved off to drink somewhere and
not chill a penny came to via tell a
damn so that is the cool thing about
having other vehicles our chairs were
able to find animals Herbie and I are
just a little disappointed that the
tracks crossed the road and we're not
communicated clearly with us because we
were actually walking in that area many
hours ago but that is the way the cookie
crumbles and here we have a beautiful
yellow bull who shouldn't go to too
close to the dam because we know what's
lurking down there but he seems to be
walking in a parallel sort of fashion
right now and they are more than one
there's at least four of them Hart in
the clearing here and this is kind of
where they like to hang out when they
get a little bit more for a better view
of any approaching lion or leopard yes
it is okay guys doing a bit of a posture
that is what jnanis tend to do it's a
bit of displacement behavior as he sees
another bull approach he raises the
parlour erection of the hairs on the
back and he stopped going into an
elaborate sort of dance he's not in a
breeding size yet he's a little bit
small but he's definitely getting there
and as soon as his friend ran towards
him he decided to do his pal erection
and stop altogether so I'm not sure the
jnanis seem to be responding right now
and they're running directly towards the
area where husana is I see Scott is
moving off over there Jojo it looks like
a design agony it looks like a sensor of
the African bush veldt indeed so these
Nala are a little bit spooked art yeah
I'm not quite sure if they know what's
going on maybe there are also
subscribers of a safari life and they
know that we generally follow leopards
Scott seems to be moving it's possible
that hasana
has moved slightly I wonder if these
nail actually clicked on the
notification to know that there is an
action broadcast in the making if a
signer comes in in error but in my
opinion and Yala bull is a little bit
too big for a ket of Rossano size but in
saying that we saw tomba with a kudu the
other day so who knows what happens
Archer under the cover of darkness all
we can do is track it and spend time and
telling you what we feel we believe ya
unique alack your name as well design
agony as we said before aren't they
marvelous so we are slowly making our
way back signers left down there
somewhere I'm not sure where Scott has
moved off to it's possible Hassan has
moved so we're making our way back as
the cover of darkness has started to
move over us and it's going to be a
beautiful night the moon is going to be
up very very late so it's gonna be a
beautiful night for stars and for those
of you in the northern hemisphere who
aren't able to join us this evening
well we're going to have a wonderful
evening under the stars so we're gonna
slowly start making her way back baby
off we go my friend
okay so we are gonna go over to Taylor
who I think is still with hooker moody
and let's see what she's going to talk
about in the final minutes of it we're
driving in a very bumpy road at the
moment I'm trying to concentrate
hang on oh wow look at this okay we're
gonna have a bit of abstraction chat but
I'm gonna show you very quickly look at
the sunset we can't really see the Sun
anymore but the beautiful colors in the
sky hey what a way to end the Safari
Leopard
another leopard very well done - of
course Scott and Steve some great
teamwork there and then of course it's
always good to appreciate the beautiful
clouds at the end of the day ha now I
was going to race after the Inca hummus
because apparently they trust from Simba
BD into Juma and then they just kept on
going and it's quite a narrow section
near Gary gates and apparently they're
already in Buffalo up for there goes our
plan out of the window however Rickson
and Taksin said that they would keep me
informed as to their movements and if
they do turn back south or turn back
west they'll call us in right away but
for now we're just gonna go on a bit of
a bumble I'm mentally preparing myself
to find a comedian this evening - that's
definitely on the cards so we'll do that
at some point oh wow
mia you've said that the sunset takes
your breath away it's beautiful this is
really really pretty this evening - I
love the contrasts of the sort of pink
orange with a beautiful blue I might
even have - shall we do this again I
think it's time for an insta story
almost Safari live page remember
Instagram you can follow us all you have
to do is search for at safari live
official
and then again we did this yesterday
actually with a sunset we'll do it again
this afternoon so I'm just gonna sit
quietly while I take this video because
I think my voice ruins it kindly that
kind of incredible there we go so now
you'll be able to see that as well on
the Safari Live official page once I get
some cellphone reception that should
load on it and we of course post
pictures there all the time so even when
we aren't live you can still get your
fix and you can see the highlights you
can see all the cool pictures from all
the presenters from the directors
everybody is a keen photographer in cat
very nice though remember to like that
page off we go down triple them so we
had a very bumpy road at the moment we
are going to try and move off of this
road I've just forgotten where the next
turn office will basically just take the
next turn off to the left and and then
we'll go exploring there's a time for
lights yeah not yet still a little bit
on the light side huka moody sadly
crushed out
he crossed outed little Gauri and but I
think we had the most amazing sciencing
of him short but sweet but those are the
best kinds of sightings I'd bet you all
agree and well we wish him well on his
adventure and we hope to see him again
soon oh here we go
hallelujah there's a road to the right
but Sebastian is very thankful for this
though although you can't tell me though
that it's worse than the roads in the
Maasai Mara those ones were horrible and
they were long exactly those are some
serious corrugations anyways well we're
gonna carry on down this road and see
where it takes us who knows maybe we'll
find some animals if we're lucky let's
go see what Scott's up to now and where
he's off to
we thought it would just race up to the
sites where tumblr had to kill this
morning and there was no sign of tumba
nor the kill so who knows what may have
happened I mean maybe young was son a
chase stumble off managed to get some
scraps and then fit on them and then
came down here I guess we'll never know
so I just wanted to go and try and see
what in fact was going on there would
have been very interesting had we have
still found tumba day with some remains
it would have indicated that obviously
he can stand up for himself against
Torresani even though husana is a little
bit bigger and older than him
and hosannas still snoozing here in the
long grass still looking very very
intently at the Egyptian geese those
seemed to be high up on his menu this
kind of flies isn't killing us any ones
we get a little tighter end that you can
actually see him now guessing he's
waiting for cover of darkness and then
he's gonna try and launch a few attacks
although there's never any cover of
darkness here because it's quite a few
big lights that illuminate this area so
you'll be best off somewhere else if
that's what he's hoping for but when are
just taking a breather he's been moving
around a fair deal it appears this
afternoon from when he was seen before
drive on quarantine
who knows what route he took to get to a
we saw Matt Tumblr's kill he seems to
have a fair have had a fairly busy time
how incredible was that sunset
Huey absolutely magical one of the best
we've seen in a while so happy that
Taylor stopped and managed to show you
that and all its glory
ah very good well it seems like the
sunset views are not quite over just yet
Steve would like to see the view from
his perspective thank you very much
the bushwalk team is on their way home I
can't help but to stop and watch the
last rays of the Sun setting I'd like to
thank her B for his assistance there's
always and Senzo we are going to be
closed down for the night we've had a
marvelous day although we weren't able
to find a sauna he was found in the end
which is magical
Herbie from you from me from Senza
absolutely fantastic afternoon I leave
you with the moment with the Sun
so folks have a fantastic evening from
the push push to walk team we're gonna
go back over to Taylor for the rest of
the drive and we will see you tomorrow
good night awesome Steve Volvo I hope
you enjoyed your Bush walk this
afternoon it sounded like a goodie now
hmm we just we were really just bumbling
I feel like we were so special what's so
special we were so privileged today to
see Hooker moody and it was such a nice
sighting of him too so I'm not really
too perturbed if we don't see any more
big cats this evening I think we're
gonna spend some time looking for the
smaller things so we're gonna be looking
for any beetles that may be crawling out
onto the road I really want to see my
first flat neck million since being back
in South Africa haven't been able to
check that off of the list just yet and
maybe it's cops or a pill spotted owl it
that'd be quite nice to a bat
another night John I think a night John
described here we can almost guarantee
if I'm going to be a little bit arrogant
just because there's so many of them
around
however the others will be difficult to
find what about a bush baby I bet you
all would like to see a bush baby Scott
got some the other night which was quite
a nice sighting of Steve actually I
think you were on camera with him yeah
yeah was it a nice sighting looked like
it from from the I think I just walked
in after Bush walk in fact and so yeah
so be looking for things like that and
who knows it's been such a warm day
there's also a possibility I've seen
some snakes coming out onto the road so
I've still got my hopes up and hopefully
finding a path better there we go our
first nocturnal creature I'm not gonna
put just a little bit for my spotlight
I'm not actually spotting and keeping
there it is it was a classic reveal well
done so I'm not gonna keep the light on
the scrub here but I just wanted to
point it out that there is a little
scrub here sitting on the road come out
of hiding which would have been
underneath a tree a shrub
underneath a fallen log keeping away
from the heats of the day and the Sun
and it even seems like the scrub here's
a little bit on the hot side tuna cats
even quite heavily this whole body is
moving slightly very nice very relaxed
but again I don't want to keep the
spotlight on it so we shall carry on and
let it go on with its ventures we will
put the infrared on in a minute actually
we're gonna do that right now in fact so
while we put our infrared on it seems as
though Scott's managed to relocate on on
husana let's go and see what he looks
like in black and white welcome back
everybody we are still sitting and
waiting patiently here with young
Hosanna we've got our infrared lights on
it's getting a bit dark now and we
really are hoping that it's gonna take
us on a little bit of an infrared
adventure where we can spy on him using
no lights that are visible to our eyes
or any other animals eyes really and
some exciting stuff happen I'm not sure
if Ted is fully on with the Inca home of
pride sadly crossed into our property
crust out of our property and then chest
a pack of wild dogs or fair kill that
would have been nice to see but happy
that the Inca home were proud have got a
little bonus meal and happy to hear that
all the wild dogs escaped unscathed
being the most successful predator that
roams these Plains not really plains
this wilderness they'll be able to make
a kill relatively easily
not to show exactly the finer details of
how much of the kill the Lions managed
to get and what exactly it was I'm
guessing was probably an Impala and
probably not much remaining because wild
dogs eat incredibly fast so the Lions
probably only got a bit of a snack and
who knows maybe they'll decide to come
back onto Gemma after their pilfered
meal and maybe they'll be around for us
in the morning
we've been spoiled rotten there recently
lots of big cats around especially
leopards I mean it's ridiculous
it was the geese flying away that's what
he is watching hmm there goes your
dinner buddy didn't have to make a plan
B
a chum I've been seeing so many
different male leopards who Komori tumba
Hosanna gajima last night as Justin gana
the old guy who used to see more than
anyone missing off the list but I mean
we couldn't theory if we see ting garnet
tomorrow we would have seen five males
within the space of 36 hours which would
be absolutely fascinating and it'll be
nice to add Tandy and a cub to the list
as well even though they're not males
but there's nearly as many lepers remove
females moving around as there are males
but we'll take whatever we can get for
the time being
Mina you would like to know why do
leopards wag their tails well to be
honest I've never really seen a leopard
wag their tail like a dog just to not
confuse anyone they kind of odd like to
say rather twitch their tail and it's
just the tip really that touches ever so
slightly from side to side he's looking
at another goose that just flew over
[Music]
yeah I mean it's an emotional indicator
when they're excited or thinking about
things I haven't you know being able to
work out any exact correlations as to
when they touch their tail but it's yeah
it's some form of indicator of their
emotions their excitement their thought
processes some songs they'll hold their
tail up high kind of arching it towards
their head when they've been spotted by
animals almost as like okay guys you've
got me I've put my hands up I come in
peace just leave me to walk through your
area I'm not trying to creep up on
anyone you can see me holding my tail up
I don't mean anything nasty so sometimes
they do that he really is tuned in this
evening
whooping has hit her own when he hears
something that excites them
christena you'd like to know if the
Leopards feel the change that's going on
with the males and yes they will
certainly be 100% clued in to what's
going on with the males and if they not
well they are not clever because it's
very important that females know what's
going on with the males that roam their
territory mainly because there are
massive for it to any Cubs that they may
have
but even possibly to themselves as
adults you know if they're trying to
defend a cub the rogue male could kill
them I'm nacho just flew past him I'm
not sure if you saw a little blue go
through the screen there see I think the
females definitely know what's going on
again sadly you know I think we missed
so much of what actually happens here
after dark and even during the day
there's just a lot of stuff that happens
here where we are not around to document
it so to be able to learn from and
understand what behavior is going on and
how much the leopards do understand and
I mean that's just us being there to see
things then of course there's the fact
that it's difficult for us to try and
comprehend you know when we heard kijima
calling last nights did was tündi nearby
could she hear it was him did she know
it was him was she comfortable with the
fact that it's him because he's being
marching along that same cut line for
many years now so that's kind of stable
and not a fit whereas the hukum or email
he was in all likelihood the male that
was vocalizing in and around the dam can
last night you know what does she think
when she hears his vocalization did she
come closer did she run away you know
there's just so much that's re very
difficult for us to just kind of guess
you know what's going on and how much
they know about what's happening
so yeah that's what I prefer to do you
know rather rather than hypothesizing
rather try and count of weights and just
see what happens as and when we get
lucky and see an interesting kind of
events happen it's kind of like saying
what would happen if you put Bob and
Susie on Mars together you know depends
what Bob in Susie's moods are who Bob
and Susie are whether they compatible
you know and you get lots of different
Bob's and Susie's on the planet so
that's my take on that I can't how much
time I got left 20 minutes come on why
take us for a stroll you can have
another five minutes snoozing and then
we expect some action from you
very good we're gonna send you across
the taylor to see what she's getting up
to price sadly still no chameleons to
report however we did put our infrared
light on so at least we've got one thing
done now let us be serious serious pants
on patients pants off let's find these
chameleons I just I cannot believe I
haven't seen one yet I mean I used to be
good at this
finding these comedians spotting them
all the way up in the trees but I don't
know why they've all been hiding from me
since I've been back perhaps they've
gone Taylor you've been due spoiled by
the bush you've seen late birds you've
seen lions you've seen wild dogs you've
seen cool birds you've seen all the
things you cannot see us there may be
hiding away from me but we're inquiry
central now lots and lots of quarry
trees and you can find comedians sitting
on them I still have yet to notice a
particular tree that chameleons prefer
because it's actually often a question
we get is what types of trees do
comedians sit on and I suppose any tree
is fine as long as it's got a bit of
cover no because you want to be sitting
on from just a dead branch not do you
please move scrub here thank you
it's awesome to scrub here very politely
to move out of the way let's have a
little look
hmmm still searching now cool breeze
you're wondering if they do road
maintenance regularly they do indeed now
typically you'll find the guys going out
with the tractors and the big graders
just after we've had a bit of rain and
the ground is compacted nicely not so
much dust around it's the best I'm just
sort of either resurface roads or even
just to regrade them again so they do
however this a couple of roads it seems
to have deteriorated but it's it's the
same roads that deteriorate quite often
and normally what it's from is not
necessarily the vehicles driving fast we
see that we see the corrugations not on
all these little roads meandering sort
of through the reserve but on the answer
so the the boundary roads triple-m gauri
main levels of boundary these are the
roads that get the corrugations Arch I
find that women have torrential
downpours often that is the number one
cause of the deterioration in the roads
and then of course we go driving on them
and it's fairly sandy up here in the
northern sabi sands is there's only a
couple of roads that have got the black
cotton soil
unlike the Maasai Mara and the Mara
triangle which pretty much at least
three-quarters of it is black cotton
soil and you have to drive on it you
don't really have a choice and so yeah
so without without the black cotton soil
that helps us a little bit but it still
creates huge erosions down on the ground
and that water sort of channels through
so that's no good so then they have to
repair them but then again those roads
that are really badly deteriorated I
find we don't actually drive on a
regular basis the ones that we are
driving quite often are maintained
fairly fairly well often you'll just go
out for a run and you'll see old Rickson
on his tractor dragging tires just
trying to give the roads a a little bit
of a helping hand to sort of fix them
all up now I found so many comedians
down here before and so I've actually
been shut down this way and back towards
Gauri Gate also who knows if the wild
dogs are gonna cross and they could be
on the move tonight it's such a lovely
evening no need for a jerseys here
than short sleeves in a shirt no short
sleeve shirts and shorts is what the
Justin's giving me some advice but I
didn't quite hear the entire advice cuz
I had to turn the game drive radio oh
hang on hang on way who's making noise
yeah there's a bird in the road what's
you're making noise for we're gonna
probably Sebastian has just told me he's
going into infrared so we're going into
infrared I can hear them it sounds like
thick knees oh no they've gotten far
away now they were sitting here maybe
some spotted thick knees they quantified
the fire down on the road it's venture a
slightly further forward and I think
we'll get them again they were making
some interesting sounds sorry
faith can I please have Justin's advice
again cuz I kind of forgot what he said
it was some advice about comedians I
need it Justin says I should look for
the comedians like I look for my sucks
because if I'm not looking for them and
I'll find them typical isn't it well
we're gonna try our best to find a good
old comedian and well the thick knees
are not cooperating either so I'm gonna
send you back to Scott who hopefully
will cooperate better than the birds
yes Hosanna is up and on the move
thankfully and I'm guessing he may come
and have another short drink and another
little puddle over here so just want to
get up ahead of him he's just off to our
right let's see what happens
well we got lucky and rude enough to add
too long for him to decide to get up and
take us on a stroll let's see where he
writes no immediate I want to try and
not use the spotlight if I don't need to
so just give it a moment or two just be
patient for a second cool breezy
wondering if we will continue watching
her son after the safari ends this
evening
probably not um I'm feeling a little bit
sick of Timon so I'm gonna go home and
rest and it's usually kind of if the
Lions are around if there's a leopard
with a kill we may got after/drive to
show some of the staff a bit of a good
time and get them arts in a baths
otherwise they'll go crazy staying in
camp all the time and I don't think we
will come up this evening although we
might another reason why you know if
he's on the move and doing this thing we
we don't use the work vehicles these
vehicles that we're on for our kind of
staff joy rides let me just move forward
in trail work out where he's gone we
keep them for business only
and without infrared lighting it can be
quite intrusive to follow an animal
after dark even though it's done quite
well be around Africa the fact that I've
been spoilt and got to see how effective
it is to follow animals using infrared
lighting I am inclined to try and only
do that if at all possible I was just
hiding behind the damn wall tucked away
the whole time we were sitting there and
we'll see him now what are you sniffing
about there
the other catches this area that they're
in cool breezes right in front of one of
the camps kind of anything beyond 7:30
in the evening is a kind of an ogre to
be driving around in front of the guests
or trying to enjoy the peace and
tranquility over the African wilderness
so that would also make it a little bit
tricky with the spot that he's in for
the time being I wonder what he can
smell there possibly some poop of an
antelope leopards do you like to eat
antelope poop
Veronica you'd like to know what the
leopards do at night do they hunt or
sleep well you'll probably find they do
a combination of the two they sleep for
a lot of time every day 16 to 20 hours
which means of course there's only four
to eight hours of movement which means
there's lots of sleep mainly during the
day but also at night so I guess just
like anyone hears domestic cats you know
full well that your cats sleep during
the day and the night but there's an
increased likelihood of them being
active after dark they like the cover of
darkness here in Africa they like the
cool weather as well
it's Sasana my son of Tambe at the
killin Hosanna made his way south along
that to track when we found him sorry
guys I'm just updating one of the Safari
vehicles as to what's going on he's just
stationary at the waterhole between the
two the Pumped the smaller pumped one on
the bigger one
at where Tara yes Stevie thanks for
confirming that you agree that some
wrist will be useful for me and my
recovery try and shake off this weird
little flu cold thingy that I've got
it's nothing serious
copy that you're welcome to join me up
all right so sorry guys it's just a few
people who are making their way into the
sizing so I just can't leave them
hanging when they talk to me on the
radio and speaking of things hanging
about it sounds like Taylor has found
you guys an interesting specimen finally
everyone at Remini on my first run since
I've been back a tumor oh it because
this no it's quite camouflaging and I've
actually just moved the light off of it
slightly and the reason why I've done
that is because you can see that I that
I median their chameleons eyes are
closed it is fast asleep
I should probably whisper don't wake it
doesn't seem to bother but obviously
don't want to put a bright light on top
of him it's not going to I say him and I
don't know you know what if it's a male
or a female but some eyes closed they
typically come aft like this at night
and we'll have a snooze they're more
active during the day in fact that's
when they'll be doing feeding sometimes
you can see them at night moving around
on the branches but tonight a chameleon
that is fast asleep which is actually
quite cool to see there's such beautiful
ones yeah see it's gonna change to
infrared now he wants to have a look and
see what it looks like I'll be quite
nice ah huh no and I turn my light off
my light oh no now that really blends in
you can just see their camouflage
actually it works quite well in black
and white
poorly you're wondering if the
chameleons will migrate at all I've
never seen a migrating convenient well I
suppose for a chameleon even if it moved
a hundred metres that would be a serious
migration so hang on Paulin let me let
me change my answer so perhaps they do
the local migrations maybe they've been
maybe this chameleon has just recently
moved to this tree
perhaps the tree that he was living on
before didn't quite have as many insects
as it was hoping for and thought right
I'm getting out of here I'm going to go
and find food elsewhere and I suppose
they will do that too but right now he's
not going to be interested in eating
anything what so ever and just going to
stick on that branch hold on tight you
can see his little feet sort of grasp
grasped grasped hold while holding on
tight ease what I'm trying to get to and
not you know this looks like it's
actually resting its head on its foot
don't you think actually kind of does
affect its front and right leg in fact
it's got an underneath his chinny
Chinchin
using it as a bit of a pillow and that's
quite nice to see his eyes all closed
faith who's directing today says that
this chameleon looks like a fossil -
dinosaur I suppose especially in the
infrared it looks quite different and
Kirstie was saying the other night we
were talking about I can't believe how
that bird was holding on to that branch
as it roosted I suppose the chameleons
doing the same thing on its little
rocking chair maybe it's a comforting
sort of feature as it sits there and I
wonder how long chameleons sleep for I'm
actually not sure about that however I'd
imagine it to be a couple of hours or so
but very nice and what a great fine
finally my first one I'm going to send
you back to Scott though because husana
is slinking through the bush
well he's kind of just slinking around
the Schwartzel and he actually if you
just got ran after a frog offer at
quarters attention but he kind of just
had a hopper skipper in a pants but not
too sure what he was hoping to latch
onto seems like he's just checking the
perimeter of this water hole we might
get a little bit of a blow out there and
he comes too close to us but Dave's too
slick on the camera for that to happen
because you just have to wait for him to
pop up there he is he's just popped out
onto the other side
sniffing around very very intently well
done to Taylor for finding that little
chameleon really really cool seeing them
it's times like this that I really
really love to know exactly what's
happening
what senses of what smells are they
picking up what are they thinking what
is exciting them here hard to be certain
clearly it is something
there's the old fleming grimace which is
allowing him to better process those
smells I'm a special organ and upper lip
let's see if he has another pull and
reprocess procedure you saying that
you've noticed susana's putting on some
weights and yes he he certainly is he's
growing up to be an impressive young
male already and I'm looking forward to
following his future and seeing how big
and strong he ends up let's hope it's
not too far from here let's hope he
doesn't do it Oh Comorian it all the way
a hundred kilometers away to the
crocodile bridge excuse me that's where
the hokum or email came from looks like
whatever the smell is that's exciting
him is very very close to our vehicle
let's see if it doesn't bring him even
closer
maybe it's from tandy last night maybe
it's from tumblr being in there and
maybe it's what some from some possible
prey good old sniff abouts
sadly in this long office is very
difficult to tell we'll see exactly what
he is doing
Veronica you have got a little bit
confused
ulaana is hosana where does he kind of
fit in and waste in Ghana Houston Ghana
basically how it works is Tenggara is
the old dominant male of Jummah and he
kind of came in and established himself
about three years ago and more recently
he's got some competition from another
mail call tohoku more email so those are
the two older males that are vying for
dominance and then we've got this
youngster who's two years old just over
two years old called Hosanna as well as
another youngster he's around just
younger than the sky called tumba so
it's for males really that we see here
having said that we did see another one
he's kind of his territories spans to
the north from our northern boundary his
name's gajima but yeah when there's lots
of lipids around it can be a little bit
confusing but don't worry Veronica a few
more suffice and you'll be in full swing
I wonder if he's gonna jump up into this
bush I've got a feeling he might
sometimes they kind of like to really
rub up against certain bushes and this
looks like one that he might try and do
just that
come on buddy
show us the vertical no Cathy yes if we
did have lion poop on our tires he would
certainly react you'd be a little bit
cautious I'm just kind of bounding
through the bushes there there's done
incredibly well to keep up with him
there and we do have some other gifts
enjoying the sighting with us and I
can't see a thing because we viewing in
infrared
they've been very sporting and not been
using their flashlights I'm feeling
quite bad because of course I can't see
anything that's just us the can see it
is the way of the future that every
vehicle should be fitted with infrared
as technology becomes more affordable
because it is definitely the least
impacts and best way to go about viewing
animals after dark
he has a slunk off too
hmm
let's see if we can reposition or not we
he's about to pop up into view he's
hitting away from us they're all done
dad
what are your plans young hasana I'm
gonna go back in check outs tumbles kill
sites search for a few scraps there
okay no and they disappear without the
assistance from their infrared light
we're gonna battle